[Musique]
messieurs bonsoir
nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle thinkerview nous
sommes en direct est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succinctement Philippe
bwix
je suis ingénieur je m'intéresse depuis
une vingtaine d'années au sujet de
transition énergétique de ressources en
particulier métalliques et autres
joyeusetés je suis également DG d'une
agence d'architecture qui s'appelle AREP
architecture urbanisme ingénierie design
etc qui travaille pas mal pour le
ferroviaire
Nicolas Millon et moi je suis aussi
ingénieur je m'intéresse depuis une
quinzaine d'années un peu problématique
de transport d'énergie de voitures
électriques j'ai été conseillé
scientifique pour Florence stratégie
pendant 4 ans et je regarde aussi les
problématiques sur de
réindustrialisation avec François
stratégie et aussi avec ma femme qui a
monté une entreprise qui fabrique des
culottes menstruelles en France et qui
s'appelle Réjane cocorico Philippe Wix
Nicolas Melian on a décidé de vous
refaire venir ce soir pour parler NRJ
s'ouvrente récession pénurie tout un tas
de petites choses
on a quand même on se voit depuis des
années c'est un sujet qui nous
perturbait depuis des années
c'est pour ça qu'on vous a reçu
plusieurs fois sur des questions de
prospective de où on en est en termes de
stock d'approvisionnement par où ça
arrive commencer à utiliser et pourquoi
et ainsi et ainsi de suite Philippe
bywix on en est où avec la souveraineté
énergétique et de matière première quand
je vois qu'il y a des gens aujourd'hui
ou peut-être avant-hier créer un qui
crée un observatoire pour tout ce qui
est approvisionnement de métaux
stratégique
vaut mieux se réveiller trop tard que
jamais mais on se pose des questions
pour l'énergie ça doit être sensiblement
pareil comment ça se passe en termes de
souveraineté comment vous voyez les
perspectives pour la France et
accessoirement pour l'Europe en termes
de comment on va survivre à ce que nous
industries vont morfler que ce soit en
termes d'accès aux matières premières
d'accès à l'énergie bon marché pour
pouvoir survivre à la concurrence
internationale des pays qui dopent un
grand coup de subventions pour attirer
les autres entreprises des autres pays
Philippe est-ce que vous avez une clé de
lecture à nous communiquer ce soir tout
va bien waouh la question la question
est longue et je sais pas si la réponse
va être conventionnelle voilà je vais je
vais prendre mon temps dans la première
chose d'abord c'est qu'il y a il y a une
prise de conscience et elle date pas de
la crise
ukrainienne il y a une prise de
conscience de
du besoin métallique pour nourrir nos
industries et pour nourrir basculer la
transition énergétique en terme
d'échelle la prise de conscience c'est
du genre depuis un an deux ans trois ans
dix ans je dirais que c'est depuis 6 ans
à peu près en fait le premier il y a eu
un premier coup de ce Mons qui m'avait
valu d'ailleurs une micro notoriété dans
les années 2010-2011 quand il y avait eu
le ban sur les exploitations de terres
rares par la Chine donc ça ça a été la
création à ce moment-là de la liste des
métaux critiques faites suivies par la
Commission européenne en France on a eu
aussi le comité des métaux stratégiques
donc il y a des des comités Théodule qui
sont lancés on va dire dans ces années
là donc ça a commencé ça a commencé
comme ça et puis finalement bon il y a
pas vraiment une restriction sur les
exportations en fait c'était pas
vraiment une volonté de nous empêcher
d'avoir des terres rares pour en faire
plein de trucs dans nos smartphones et
ailleurs c'était plutôt une volonté de
monter dans la chaîne de valeur au lieu
de vous vendre des oxydes de terres
rares je vais vous vendre des
luminosaures des petits trucs qui
servent à faire des couleurs dans les
écrans ou même je vais vous vendre voilà
c'était ça l'idée c'était un peu un
combat industriel Ess moins que le Japon
d'ailleurs pour ça que le Japon pendant
plusieurs années racontait qu'il
trouvait plein de trucs au fond des
océans qui allaient trouver des réserves
de terrain incroyables pas loin de chez
eux c'était une manière un petit peu de
voilà d'équilibrer d'un point de vue
géopolitique ça et puis à partir de
2015-2016 on a vu arriver des rapports
par exemple de la Banque mondiale de
l'Agence internationale de l'énergie de
l'OCDE
qui voilà tous se sont mis à pointer
les besoins
nécessaires donc soit en grand métaux de
type cuivre nickel zinc soit en petits
métaux de spécialité donc ça peut être
certaines terres rares comme néody me
disposium ça peut être le cobalt ou le
lithium dans les batteries les choses
comme ça et que alors en fonction des
technologies auxquelles on allait faire
appel en fonction des vitesses de
déploiement éventuels des voitures
électriques etc
et bien que voilà il va falloir en
sortir un sacré bon paquet je crois que
le dernier rapport de je crois que c'est
en 2021 de l'agence internationale de
NRJ disait il va falloir faire 60 fois
60 sur le lithium par exemple en termes
de rythme d'extraction annuel donc c'est
quand même pas mal ça veut dire qu'il
faut mettre quand même pas mal de trucs
en production et puis ça peut être fois
5 fois 10 fois 15 selon les métaux donc
une espèce de gigantesque accélération
qui va être nourrie par énergie
renouvelable
stockage et en particulier dans les
voitures électriques et puis dans une
moindre mesure par la numérisation du
monde qui continue un peu à voilà on va
dire à s'accélérer ou ça ça dépendra un
peu du nombre de chaussures connectées
qu'on décidera d'avoir en 2030 mais
voilà c'est un peu l'idée donc ça c'est
cette prise de conscience là maintenant
elle est faite
et la crise ukrainienne elle vient en
fait rajouter une couche là dessus en
disant bah tiens au fait la Russie par
exemple c'est pas juste un grand
producteur de charbon de gaz de pétrole
c'est aussi un grand producteur de
titane de nickel de platinoïdes donc
platine palladium donc il y a eu un peu
des sueurs froides dans le monde de
l'aéronautique au début de la guerre sur
le mode ou la la est-ce qu'on va
continuer à réussir à faire nos pièces
aéronautiques en titane des choses comme
ça donc
c'est voilà ça ça c'est je pense assez
bien installé et puis il y a eu aussi la
question de alors avant même la question
de la souveraineté il y a eu la question
de l'exposition pour moi aux chaînes de
valeur mondiales hyper optimisées
alors ça c’était plutôt lié à covid et
à cette à ce moment un peu en 2021 qui a
été à la fois le résultat d'un
déstockage massif dans des industries
qui voilà avaient besoin de limiter la
casse en 2020 pour celles qui sont un
peu arrêtées la numérisation qui a fait
vraiment décoller
les besoins additionnels d'ordinateurs
et autres et du coup ça a créé notamment
cette tension sur les microprocesseurs
il y a eu avant il y a eu les vélos il y
avait eu pas mal de trucs comme ça bon
et les microprocesseurs à Taïwan donc en
2021 qui fait que du coup il y a ça
arrêtait des chaînes de voiture etc et
donc ça ça a été je pense un coup de
saut de Mons supplémentaire sur le fait
de dire ou la lame en fait on dépend de
pas mal de trucs voilà et comment est-ce
qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on va faire donc
voilà on en est là aujourd'hui et je
sais pas si tu veux compléter du coup
Nicolas parce que je commence à un long
tunnel mais voilà cette cette
dépendance elle est réelle alors ensuite
la souveraineté c'est un bien grand mot
tout le monde s'y intéresse
effectivement y compris dans les
ministères et tout ça et au niveau
européen il y a pas de souci en fait la
souveraineté elle est un petit peu elle
est toujours virtuelle je dirais
c'est-à-dire que quand on commence à
descendre sur la question des matières
premières il y a toujours toujours eu
échange en fait entre les entre les pays
en fait et on peut remonter hyper loin
dans l'histoire en fait Rome n'était pas
en souveraineté parce que ils
importaient de la soie de la pourpre
de la soie de chine de la pourpre de la
myrte de l'Arabie heureuse et je sais
pas quoi et et Athènes même avant et
pour fabriquer en bateau il fallait
qu'ils aillent emmerd noir ou je sais
pas quoi pour aller chercher du bois
parce qu'il y en avait plus trop chez
eux donc il y a toujours eu des échanges
et en fait c'est la souveraineté elle
n'existe pas réelle enfin la capacité à
dire je vais réindustrer chez moi je
vais rouvrir des mines je vais me
débrouiller et maîtriser toute la chaîne
de valeur c'est pas possible en fait la
souveraineté elle vient du fait qu'on a
des monnaies d'échange donc du fait que
ben voilà je toi tu as du lithium ou du
cobalt moi j'ai autre chose et puis bah
on peut échanger et faire un truc on
peut discuter des termes de l'échange
pendant longtemps dans les années 70
enfin 50 60 70 avec le développement
c'était il y avait les détériorations
des termes de l'échange on disait qu'on
exploité des pays du Sud voilà mais
c'est ça la question et donc il y a un
moment où peut-être on a eu en affaire
ce monde du numérique ce monde sans
usine et puis en fait voilà on s'est
aperçu qu'à un moment il nous restait
plus que le french cancan et la Tour
Eiffel en monnaie d'échange et peut-être
c'est la baguette on sait pas c'est vrai
parce qu'en fait en réalité on a quand
même de l'aéronautique on a des choses
comme ça mais c'était un peu l'idée donc
à un moment où effectivement de
réindustrialiser un certain nombre de
choses peut être intéressant mais il
faut sans doute le faire en s'appuyant
sur les forces qu'on a et pas essayer de
reconstituer des des trucs intégralement
parce que c'est beaucoup trop complexe
Nicolas j'entends votre droite la
réindustrialisation comment ça se passe
la réindustrialisation avec de l'énergie
difficilement accessible à des tarifs
compliqués comment ça se passe quand la
Chine
s'accapare ou arrive à avoir tous les
contrats de gaz naturel liquéfié
jusqu'en 2026 comment ça se passe quand
la concurrence sur les marchés
financiers pour avoir accès à ces
exploitations énergétiques ce temps
comment on fait pour réindustrialiser et
attendez même pas réindustrialisé
juste survivre comment on fait je vais
continuer sur ce que disait Philippe je
vais prendre un exemple l'exemple un peu
de la transition énergétique qui sont
les voitures électriques les voitures
électriques en fait historiquement en
tout cas à date ou la Chine contrôle 80%
de la chaîne de valeur c'est-à-dire que
non seulement en fait il possède les
usines d'extraction parfois de cobalt en
République de mes démocratique du Congo
de lithium ensuite ce cobalt et celui
qui aime quand il est extrait il va
enchaine pour être raffiné c'est là où
il contrôle 80% de la chaîne de valeur
les cellules sont fabriquées et après
elles sont envoyées en Europe et donc
l'Europe s'en est rendu compte et donc
ils ont décidé de faire un Airbus des
batteries donc de se dire les batteries
c'est quand même 40% de la valeur dans
la voiture on va essayer de les
fabriquer chez nous plutôt qu'en Chine
et donc il y a des projets d'assemblage
de batterie en France
sur le papier c'est plutôt une bonne
idée en France en Allemagne
mais donc aujourd'hui on va avoir de la
fabrication de ces batteries là mais
pour fabriquer ses batteries sur rendu
compte qu'il y avait des métaux dedans
donc par exemple
soulève dans son discours de l'Union au
mois de juin me dit mais bon on a pas de
pétrole on n'a pas de légumes non plus
donc on va faire des stocks stratégiques
de lithium sauf que pour l'instant
l'Europe est-ce qu'elle veut faire c'est
relocaliser le premier maillon de la
chaîne de valeur mais après il faut
assembler les cellules c'est une chose
après il faut les fabriquer il faut
fabriquer les poudres qui servent pour
entrer dans les cellules il faut
raffiner les métaux et pour l'instant
toutes ces étapes là elle reste en Chine
aujourd'hui on a un prix du gaz
multiplié par entre 10 et 20 un prix
d'électricité multiplié par 17 ans
manque de bol comment est-ce que vous
fabriquez une
cellule de batterie pour une voiture
électrique vous mettez ça dans un four
en fait et le four il marche à quoi il
marche avec du gaz et en Europe pour
l'instant c'est plutôt du gaz de
Monsieur Poutine et donc qu'est-ce qui
se passe dans ce très beau projet très
cher à notre gouvernement on a eu quand
même des annonces des usines des emplois
associés à ça ben il se passe par
exemple que à Berlin Tesla qui venait
faire une gigafactory donc ils ont fait
une usine d'assemblage de voiture et à
côté des femmes usine de batterie
manque de pot cette usine pour l'instant
est en pause pourquoi parce que en même
temps Joe Biden a fait en août ce dont
rêvait Donald Trump c'est de donner une
incitation une prime pour les voitures
fabriquées sur le sol américain avec une
batterie fabriquée sur le sol américain
donc ça c'est sa viole toutes les règles
comme à l'international bien évidemment
et
donc Tesla s'est dit ben moi au lieu
d'aller fabriquer mes voitures et mes
batteries en Europe cette usine de
batterie je vais la mettre aux
États-Unis et donc tous les outils qui
étaient destinés à cette usine vont
partir dans l'usine de Texas de Austin
au Texas teslaï en premier exemple il y
a un autre exemple qui est le nordval
qui est une autre très grosse entreprise
de fabrication de batterie qui devait
mettre une usine de batterie en
Allemagne et qui est en train de
réfléchir de la mettre plutôt aux
États-Unis et donc aujourd'hui nous en
Europe on se retrouve coincé entre deux
géants de mastodontes
les échos je crois aujourd'hui titré on
se retrouve broyé
entre les États-Unis d'un côté et la
Chine de l'autre et malheureusement
toutes nos velléités et toutes nos
initiatives pour réindustrialiser le
pays aujourd'hui en fait quand vous
n'avez pas d'énergie bon marché
malheureusement ça va être très très
compliqué
donc ça va être très très compliqué mais
c'est faisable
non et il faut il faut défendre ce
gouvernement ils essayent mais est-ce
qu'il faut un peu les remettre le nez
dans la réalité c'est-à-dire que là il y
a beaucoup d'effets d'annonces ça
communique beaucoup ça communique ça
agit que les bras ça dandine les mains
ça prêche avec ferveur l'arrière
industrialisation on va s'en sortir
quand vous entendez ce discours
politique vous qui avez les vrais
chiffres les vrais disponibilités les
vrais contrats ou et positionner qui à
gauche comme à droite qui se positionne
comme vous avez un prisme de lecture à
long terme au minimum de 3 à 5 ans
quand vous les entendez parler ça vous
donne du courage ou vous les prenez
vraiment pour des clowns
juste pour je pense qu'il faut mettre
les choses dans le contexte on parle
beaucoup des industriels et on parle
beaucoup du coup l'énergie effectivement
le coup l'énergie pour les industriels
l'industrie c'est un tiers d'électricité
un tiers de gaz pour l'énergie et puis
le reste d'autres énergies
pour beaucoup d'industriels c'est une
multiplication par 3 par 5 ou par plus
de la facture et qu'on dit ah oui c'est
très difficile effectivement quand vous
multipliez par ça si ça représente 2% de
votre chiffre d'affaires et que ça
reprend demain 10% mais il vous reste
plus de marge complètement le problème
c'est que si avec eux le coût l'énergie
entre guillemets ça pourrait presque
passer mais le problème c'est qu'en plus
de ça vous vous ajoutez une baisse de
l'activité
puisqu'au niveau mondial avec
l'inflation qu'on a en fait nous-même
créé aussi avec le choc de la demande
après le covid en imprimant beaucoup
d'argent créé cette inflation là et donc
c'est là pour la combattre l'inflation
qu'est-ce qu'on fait on augmente les
taux d'intérêt au niveau de la Fed au
niveau de la BCE et donc plus on
augmente les taux d'intérêt plus on va
envoyer l'économie dans le mur donc on
va voir une
hausse des coûts de production baisse de
l'activité et ça va concerner tous les
industriels et le troisième effet kiss
cool parce que cette fois-ci il y en a
trois c'est qu'avec le covid vous avez
beaucoup de gens qui ont survécu avec
des prêts garantis par l'État avec des
charges l'URSSAF qui ont été complément
été décalés et là aujourd'hui on leur
demande de rembourser on le demande de
rembourser ses prêts de payer ses
charges avec une activité en baisse et
des coûts qui augmentent ça ça c'est le
cocktail explosif malheureusement pour
que ça se passe très mal est-ce que le
gouvernement a conscience
j'ai redire peut-être plus aujourd'hui
qu'hier et malheureusement
il y a quand même des solutions si vous
voulez à mettre en place là on parle
malheureusement dans un mur à une force
extrêmement violente
l'Europe elle existe pas nous tétaniser
je vais pas vous
en fait l'Europe l'Europe et notamment
l'Allemagne qui représente une très
grosse partie de l'Europe existe grâce à
un accès à l'énergie bon marché mais ça
a priori c'est terminé donc j'en profite
les perspectives sur les prix d'énergie
mis à part le fait qu'on se tape une
récession mondiale catastrophique qui
ferait baisser la demande et donc les
prix les prix à long terme de l'énergie
sont partis pour augmenter
je pense qu'on est dans c'est fini mais
je pense qu'on est quand même parti dans
un monde avec de l'énergie bon marché et
derrière nous ça va peut-être pas faire
x 10 x 20 mais ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est que parfois quand vous avez
beaucoup qui augmente vous dites bon là
on me demande une augmentation de 10% de
mes coups de 15 %, c'est beaucoup 10 %
15 %, il faut pouvoir les encaisser
mais quand on parle de l'énergie c'est
pas 10% ou 15 %, c'est 500 %, c'est
1000% en fait ça n'existe dans un monde
on peut encaisser un tel choc
moi je suis personnellement allé voir
avec
une personne le cabinet d'année espany
rue nation pour lui dire écoutez
bon la session est telle qu'elle est
nous avons décidé de nous passer
l'énergie russe bon marché le pétrole et
le gaz est-ce que vous avez regardé
avant de prendre ses décisions
s'il y avait des alternatives
la réponse est non nous on a regardé on
a fait le travail sur le pétrole on a
fait le travail sur le gaz ce qui nous
c'est c'est moi personnellement et le
chiffre project a fait une étude sur ce
sujet là et une autre personne qui
travaille avec le chiffre qui a regardé
et sur le pétrole et sur le gaz qui
s'appelle Olivier rech et qu'un expert
des plus grand expert mondial sur
l'énergie
il y a pas d'alternative
pas forcément une alternative peut-être
pas au même prix 5 fois plus cher sauf
que celle là on voit pas la payer
Philippe alors sur l'aspect du
gouvernement moi j'ai presque du mal à
leur en vouloir mais j'ai l'impression
que je deviens bienveillant en
vieillissant aussi voilà non c'est à
dire on sent bien quand même enfin je
peux sens presque solidaire de la
panique en fait d'une certaine manière
non mais évidemment elle est pas elle
est pas elle est pas jouée mais voilà
l'idée c'est dire Olivier on va gérer à
la fois le très court terme très court
terme on sent quand même que dans le
rétroviseur il y a un peu de bonnet
rouge il y a un peu de gilet jaune
demain je sais pas quoi autre chose donc
il y a cette inquiétude énorme de de la
capacité du pays à faire société quelque
part et à encaisser des chocs de ce type
là donc
c'est une première chose et donc faut
avec toutes les questions peut-être
qu'on y reviendra j'en sais rien mais
d'exemplarité les trucs un petit peu
irritants avec j'explique qu'il faut la
ceinture mais je rentre en jet enfin
voilà on peut on parlait plein de trucs
comme ça donc ça ça tend le pays et puis
on voit bien qu'on n'est pas dans un
dans une situation qui permet d'avoir un
débat public relativement serein donc
effectivement donc on est un peu en mode
panique mais comme ces gens sont
essaient d'être vraiment sérieux ils
sont dans une logique de dire il faut
qu'on gère le court terme donc passer
deux hivers mais vous inquiétez pas on
s'inscrit dans une logique vraiment de
de long terme on est toujours stratégie
nationale bas carbone et du coup on
place les premières briques finalement
tout ça c'est on investit et l'hydrogène
etc bon et en fait moi ce qui me
perturbe plus que que les deux hivers
même si bon ben voilà peut-être j'ai vu
que le nombre de plaids vendus abattu
des records donc c'est super tout le
monde c'est qui on est prêt pour le 19
degrés c'est vrai qu'il y a des petits
côtés un peu marrant de tout ça aussi
c'est voilà au bureau il fait très froid
et puis un moment on aurait eu des
piquets de grève avec la température qui
peut faire et en fait non bah là les
gens dire oui il fait froid c'est bien
en respecter 19 degrés bon donc dans les
écoles dans certaines cases c'est 10
degrés alors voilà ça c'est quand la
chaudière vraiment vraiment mal réglé
donc c'est je pense c'est pas ça l'idée
mais donc il y a un peu de il y a un peu
tout ça mais globalement moi ce qui me
fait peur c'est plutôt la collectivité
qui ne peut plus payer
je pense que c'est quand même non je
pense pas qu'il y a des je pense qu'ils
ferment les piscines avant de mettre les
écoles de degrés enfin je dans les
arbitrages un peu douloureux
en piscine bon mais du coup moi ce qui
me fait plus peur c'est la question du
moyen terme c'est-à-dire que de pas
avoir forcément
des des décideurs globalement qui ont
compris la mesure de la sobriété
systémique qui va falloir mettre en
place c'est quoi la mesure et de de
reconnaître y compris dans tous les
scénarios je vais vous donner un ou deux
exemples mais dans tous les scénarios là
qui sont sortis à l'automne par en 2021
ou début 2022 donc c'est Adem nouvelle
Adem transition RTE nos futurs 2050
et puis
Negawatt qui a fait aussi sa mise à jour
début 2022 tout le monde reconnaît qu'il
faut faire enfin la sobriété et jusqu'à
présent tient c'est super utile c'est
vachement bien maintenant c'est pas ça
c'est que c'est au cœur du truc si on
fait pas de la sobriété et on va pas
réussir à faire la transition
énergétique et on va pas réussir à tenir
une trajectoire qui nous amène à 2050
c'est quoi la sobriété confinement
énergétique
bon c'est alors après ça va être moi je
pense pas que ça soit ça ou que ça c'est
à dire que aujourd'hui ce qui est gênant
c'est que on a que des mesures soit des
mesures d'efficacité d'efficacité pas de
sobriété donc c'est par exemple de dire
à des entreprises de décaler des
consommations etc ou alors d'aller
chercher des processus industriels on en
trouvera qui seront plus efficaces même
si un moment au bout d'un moment on va
quand même atteindre une asymptote mais
c'est on est plutôt dans la mesure de
individuelle on va dire chauffer à 19
degrés chez vous et puis et puis
covoituré quoi ça peut être très
efficace il y a pas de problème chauffer
à 19 plutôt qu'à 22 enfin pour ceux qui
étaient chauffés à 22 tout le monde
n'était pas chauffé à 22 mais ça c'est
les autoroutes à 110 ça serait assez
efficace aussi effectivement même pour
d'autres il y a même des co bénéfices
comme on dit sur la pollution sur sur
les accidents etc donc ça serait ça
serait pas mal mais effectivement là on
retrouve on retombe sur la question
gilet jaune slash poney rouge
mais par exemple sur la rénovation
énergétique aujourd'hui on a du rénover
plus exactement le chiffre et de l'ordre
il me semble 60 000 logements
intégralement l'année dernière avec ma
prime rénove en 2021 il y a eu de
l'ordre de 800000 gestes unitaires donc
c'est-à-dire j'ai isole les combles ou
je change la chaudière ou je change les
fenêtres mais unitaires donc ça ça fait
pas baisser tout le logement à ce niveau
là pour tenir le rythme de la de la
stratégie nationale ba carbone donc
inscrite dans la loi à date enfin ça va
être révisé mais pour l'instant c'est ça
il faut multiplier par 20 cette vitesse
là faut rénover 20 fois plus que ce
qu'on a rénové l'année dernière donc on
va le faire avec quel moyen humain
éventuellement peut-être qu'elle
matériau quels moyens financier
personnellement c'est trop rien pour
l'instant c'est ma prime rénove c'est
cool quoi ouais donc il y a quand même
ce sujet là après on peut se dire oui
bien sûr les batteries on va avoir un
sujet de batterie etc mais encore une
fois de quoi parle-t-on c'est-à-dire que
si on prend une je prends toujours cet
exemple là je suis désolé pour les gens
qui connaîtraient déjà mais en toute
petite voiture qui va faire allez j'en
sais rien 700 kg et Cora 150 km
d'autonomie de batterie donc il permet
aux gens qui peuvent pas monter sur un
vélo électrique ou je sais pas quoi de
faire quand même pas mal de trucs et
puis je prends le char d'assaut de 2
tonnes qui va avoir 800 km d'autonomie
et comme ça je peux aussi partir en
vacances sans avoir besoin de rebrancher
suivez mon regard et bien entre ces deux
objets là j'ai besoin de 10 à 15 fois
plus de batterie dans le deuxième par
rapport au premier donc donc oui alors
est-ce qu'il va y avoir pénurie est-ce
qu'on aura du mal à se battre ça dépend
est-ce qu'on va développer un milliard
de bagnoles qui seront des pots de
yaourt ou est-ce qu'on va développer un
milliard de bagnoles qui seront les
chars d'assaut ou est-ce qu'on va
développer 300 millions de bagnoles et
puis le reste avec la foule qui tue de
petites de petits véhicules
intermédiaires de vélo cargo de je sais
pas quoi qu'on pourrait faire et bien en
fonction de ça l'incertitude géologique
à côté c'est c'est peanuts la réalité
c'est l'incertitude de la demande
quelque part et moi je pense que ce
qu'on n'arrive pas à faire pour
l'instant parce qu'évidemment on est en
mode panique mais c'est qu'en réalité
avant bien sûr qu'il y a un aspect un
peu d'austérité dans cette sobriété un
peu pénible c'est sympa de se balader
tout nu dans son truc à 23 degrés quand
il gèle dehors bien sûr mais
il n'y a pas que ça c'est à dire que on
n'est pas plus heureux parce que on
change d'aspirateur tous les 5 ans
enfin ma connaissance donc peut-être
j'ai pas pris le smartphone exprès parce
que ça peut-être ça rend heureux de
changer de smartphone tous les deux ans
mais pour l'aspirateur je pense que tout
le monde sera d'accord pourtant c'est ce
qu'on fait donc on est en rentrant dans
un monde qui serait beaucoup plus de la
de la réparation finalement du
patrimoine qui va de l'objet le plus
simple jusque au plus grandes
infrastructures en passant par les
bâtiments etc en fait il y a un gisement
phénoménal d'économie d'énergie et
d'économie de matériaux des qu'on sait
pas aller chercher pour l'instant parce
que c'est plus systémique c'est plus
complexe à mettre en oeuvre un autre
exemple
quand vous prenez une bouteille de verre
par exemple et vous la jetez dans votre
comme il faut vous la casser ça refait
une bouteille de verre je vais prendre
la version sympa aussi a priori ça
refait une bouteille de verre j'ai
économisé 20% de l'énergie par rapport à
une bouteille neuve c'est à dire rien
d'accord si vous jetez une canette
d'aluminium vous économiser 80 %
d'énergie parce que l'aluminium voilà
mais le vert il est déjà transformé du
coup physiquement et donc on économise
que la partie qui est de le transformer
de passer de sable en verre mais par
contre il faut le chauffer il faut le
refondre il faut refaire un bouteille
donc c'est peanuts et donc en faisant un
monde où on est capable de faire de la
consigne et de remplir une bouteille de
lait avec une bouteille de vin ou avec
une bouteille d'huile ou avec une
bouteille de jus d'orange ou de je sais
pas quoi et bien voilà on économiserait
des quantités phénoménales et
aujourd'hui les varier qu'est-ce qu'ils
font ils sont là en disant ah oui j'ai
un problème parce que le gaz machin bah
oui mais tu es gentil on en a pas besoin
en fait toutes ces bouteilles là si on
est cassé pas bêtement à la fin et qu'on
arrivait à avoir une organisation qui
permette de dire les logisticiens les
distributeurs les fabricants ce qu'on
bouteille les clients tout le monde en
arrive à un truc avec plus de circuits
courts etc donc c'est tout ça qu'il faut
réussir à mettre en oeuvre et évidemment
ça se fait pas en deux hivers ça se fait
pas en claquant les doigts et ça se fait
pas avec des annonces à coup de milliard
Nicolas le confinement énergétique on
parle de deux hivers on a un prisme de
lecture
aussi
pénétrant qu'une pointe de diamants à
deux hivers c'est quand même bien alors
est-ce que vous on parle pas de de
divers on parle de trois bah en fait
déjà de passer celui-là on regarde
celui-là on se dit bon cool il y a eu un
très très gros réchauffement climatique
en octobre avec le mois le plus chaud
depuis un paquet de temps donc on a
consommé aucun gaz on est on a eu
beaucoup très peu on a eu des prix
négatifs sur le gaz puisque en fait tous
les réservoirs en Europe étaient pleins
les bas il y avait 35 bateaux qui
tournaient
pour pouvoir livrer leur gaz à l'Europe
qui avait fait beaucoup d'achat qui
avait notamment acheté beaucoup de gaz
naturel russe ou chinois
et puis là donc on se dit bon l'été
l'été cette année ça va bien se passer
il était d'après on verra mais en fait
ce qu'on constate c'est que là
j'entendais hier Olivier Véran qui
disait ah on constate que effectivement
il y a des liens de la sobriété le plan
de sobriété du gouvernement fonctionne
la preuve la consommation a décidé de 5
% or et fait de température mais qui a
consommé moins
c'est pas les particuliers c'est les
entreprises confirmées c'est les
industries concernées c'est au fond de
nos confirmés donc en fait l'effort de
sobriété demandée par le gouvernement ça
s'appelle des entreprises qui mettent la
clé sous la porte est-ce que c'est
vraiment cette sobriété là qu'on veut
parce que s'il est l'entreprise mais
avec les sous la porte forcément un
embaucher certaines personnes et donc je
pense que on a on a un petit souci
pourquoi je disais que c'était pas que
de dire parce que donc sur le gaz on va
dire qu'on va peut-être passer cet hiver
là l'hiver prochain si on a encore des
températures acceptables et à mon avis
avec
le nombre d'industriels qui vont soit
fermer des définitivement soit
délocaliser aux États-Unis ou en Chine
la consommation de gaz va beaucoup
baisser grosso modo la consommation de
gaz en Europe c'est un tiers pour faire
de l'électricité un tiers pour se
chauffer et un tiers pour l'industrie
donc si on baisse déjà d'un tiers notre
consommation ou une grosse partie ça va
ça va ça va diminuer mais le problème
c'est que c'est pas résolu pour les pour
les hivers suivants parce qu'en fait
comment est-ce qu'on a permis comment
est-ce qu'on a pu s'approvisionner en
gaz on a les le racheter au chinois au
Japon
aux Indiens au pakistanais au banglady à
5 à 10 fois le prix donc ces gens-là ils
ont plus de gaz donc c'est en mode
coupure de courant délestage on appelle
ça un délestage maintenant
et donc si la Chine continue
effectivement à nous faire 10 ans de
zéro covid avec du stop and go on pourra
toujours acheter le gaz des Chinois
vu la situation actuelle je sais pas
combien de temps ça va durer mais il est
probable comme un moment donné la Chine
la Chine reparte mais on n'a pas
l'internative on va sur le marché du gaz
naturel qui fait qui a marché mondial il
y a quelques producteurs qui sont
locatar qui sont les États-Unis qui sont
l'Australie qui sont la Russie le
Qatar est l'Australie vend beaucoup au
pays asiatique qui sont la Chine le
Japon et la Corée du Sud les États-Unis
on est pas mal à l'Asie mais avec le
conflit en Ukraine ils ont trouvé un
débouché important en Europe donc nous
on est la France premier je l'avais déjà
dit mais on a été cinq mois d'affilée
première importateur mondial quand même
de gaz de schiste vous savez ce gaz
naturel c'est le meilleur moi c'est ma
préférée mais on avait déjà été champion
du monde il y a quelques années ça fait
depuis 2016 que moi je suis au gage chez
moi peut-être que j'ai un peu de gaz de
schiste bon j'en suis désolé pour les
Américains qui vont subir les
et puis accessoirement pour le métal qui
va être libéré la production etc mais
gros en gros sur le marché du gaz
naturel on a des concurrents qui sont la
Chine la Corée du Sud le Japon eux ils
en veulent beaucoup de gaz naturel et
donc on va pouvoir se battre contre eux
mais on va le payer très cher et nous
industriels je donne souvent un exemple
au début des années 2010 en Europe avec
le développement du gaz de schiste aux
États-Unis le prix du gaz a été trois
fois moins cher aux États-Unis qu'on
Europe qu'est-ce qui s'est passé un
certain nombre de sites d'usines
chimiques pour lesquelles le gaz soit
utilisé pour l'énergie soit comme
matière première on fermait en Europe
pour s'installer aux États-Unis parce
que c'était trois fois plus cher
c'était trois fois moins cher aux
États-Unis aujourd'hui on est pas à
trois
on est à 6 on est à 7 donc sur les sur
toutes les l'industries que tu utilises
du gaz fabrication de batterie pour les
voitures électriques fabrication
d'engrais toute la chimie on va ça va
être dessiné regardez juste BASF qui a
une des plus gros sites en Allemagne 50
000 personnes et qui annoncent que eux
de toute façon ils vont devoirs ils vont
devoir délocaliser d'un côté aux
États-Unis de l'autre côté en Chine ils
avaient déjà commencé si vous voulez
mais qu'est-ce qui se passe comme en
2008 comme vous allez avoir une crise
économique et que vous allez avoir donc
trop de capacités par rapport à la
demande on ferme les capacités qui
coûtent les plus chères où elles sont en
Europe et donc comme en 2008 on a fermé
beaucoup de capacités en Europe de
l'Ouest là ça va être la même chose 2023
c'est pas des bonnes nouvelles cela dit
ça ouvre une une question
qui est un peu liée à la question de
souveraineté aussi
qui est la question du libre-échange
c'est à dire que ça c'est aussi une
nouveauté de la fin de la décennie
précédente on va dire ou du début des
années 2020 c'est que jusqu'à présent on
avait une Commission Européenne j'ai
bien commission pas les États membres
qui étaient farouchement contre toute
taxe aux frontières contre tous
mécanismes protection douanières hors le
normatif c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que
les les traités internationaux ils
étaient vraiment épais vraiment sur la
question de normative mais on s'est
retrouvé du coup avec des mécanismes par
exemple de de trading des missions de
CO2 ou du coup des cimentiers
s'installaient en Égypte en Turquie je
sais pas quoi pour ensuite venir
apporter le clinquaire dans les ports
européens et du coup ne subissaient pas
finalement le surcoût des émissions de
CO2 du ciment qui est très émetteur le
ciment Charm el shake s'il avait été un
pays c'était le troisième mondial ex
aequo avec l'acier derrière la Chine des
États-Unis donc c'est à poids lourd d'un
point de vue chimique il faut émettre du
CO2 faut chauffer beaucoup et en plus
ils mettent du CO2 donc du coup ils
apportaient le claquèrent et puis après
il reconstituer les études du ciment sur
place et donc sans aucune taxe
apportation et sans payer finalement ce
schéma donc ça ça a été reconnu et du
coup la commission maintenant on a je
pense qu'en plus on s'est aperçu que le
doux commerce c'était pas forcément la
paix mondiale donc maintenant on est
plus en mode un peu simplifier comme on
a pu l'être pendant quelques décennies
sur le mode ouais les taxes douanières
mais vous voulez la guerre en fait quoi
voilà quoi non aujourd'hui la Commission
européenne dit oui il faut un mécanisme
d'ajustement aux frontières pour mener
la transition si on veut donner un prix
au carbone et faire la transition en
Europe il faut donner il faut donner un
prix au carbone entre alors c'est hyper
compliqué parce que comment est-ce que
on taxe le produit fini versus la
matière première et tout donc tout ça
sera difficile les États membres jusqu'à
présent bah ça dépend l'Allemagne qui
est effectivement très exportatrice et
en particulier de de machines outils de
voitures de luxe et éventuellement de de
chimie de spécialités et pas hyper
branché par tout ce qui peut être taxé à
l'import enfin parce que justement avec
des inquiétudes de de
réaction des pays des gros pays sur la
canne elle importe et donc pour moi
c'est exactement la même question cette
histoire de enfin coût de l'énergie et
où coût du CO2 enfin du carbone et de
l'énergie carbonée c'est de dire un
moment si tu as pas un ensemble
un peu suffisamment gros mais dans
lequel tu essaies de défendre un peu
contre l'extérieur bah effectivement tu
subis tous les toutes les possibilités
d'arbitrage économiques d'entreprise qui
sont quand même globalement devenus
voilà assez grande pour finalement ne
pas avoir forcément de de d'envie très
national et donc tu as ces mécanismes là
mais tu pourrais aussi dire demain j'ai
des engrais je veux que ces engrais ils
soient faits sur le sol français sinon
je taxerai chaque tonne d'ammonitrate
qui arrive dans un port européen et à ce
moment-là bah ça partirait pas aux
États-Unis même à tel prix tu vois pour
donc il y a des questions faut quand
même des mécanismes de protection
possible alors pour passer soit pour
passer un peu le cap soit surtout pour
se dire on a besoin de moins justement
de souveraineté donc on refuse que les
engrais soit produits à l'autre bout du
monde par les États-Unis qui sont
copains mais bon c'est pas pour combien
de temps ou etc et voilà donc c'est
c'est difficile à mettre en oeuvre parce
que il faut derrière que les États
membres soient ok mais théoriquement ça
serait possible il faut que c'est un peu
notre problème comme tu le disais comme
l'Allemagne il y a une relation très
très proche avec la Chine mais ils sont
pieds poignet que les chinois ils vont
toujours se poser des mesures qui
pourraient restreindre les exportations
de la Chine vers l'Europe puisque eux de
leur côté ils le paierait d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça que leur balance
commerciale souffre beaucoup en ce
moment c'est les exploitations vers la
Chine qu'on beaucoup baissé mais il y a
juste quelques exemples on va rester sur
la voiture électrique
comment est-ce qu'on fait pour
réindustrialiser alors Philippe a parlé
effectivement de cette ajustement
carbone frontières qui devrait être mis
en place entre 2027 et 2030 qui ne va
concerner dans un premier temps que
l'acier le ciment l'aluminium peut-être
l'électricité aussi donc probablement
dans ce qu'il y aura encore des
fonderies d'acier en 2030 spacieux du
ciment peut-être un peu plus mais
qu'est-ce que ça va faire ça va faire
que les gens au lieu de faire la scie en
Europe ils vont le faire en dehors de
l'Europe vont faire le produit fini ils
vont le réimporter parce que lui le
produit fini il sera pas soumis à cette
taxe donc il y a des moyens de
contourner et comment le contour en
délocalisant encore plus il y a d'autres
façons plus intelligentes moi j'aime
bien regarder ce qui se passe au niveau
des États-Unis par exemple qu'est-ce
qu'ils font aux États-Unis tu t'achètes
une voiture
il est obligatoire de marquer sur la
voiture l'étiquette ou la voiture était
assemblée ou le moteur a été assemblé ou
la voiture de la boîte de vitesse a été
assemblée ça c'est interdit en Europe
pourquoi parce que ça va faire de la
discrimination entre les pays et la
seule chose on doit mettre le nom du
pays c'est sur les fruits les légumes et
peut-être la viande
et pour ça on pourrait déjà aider
fringues hors Union européenne c'est ça
mais pas un traduit
c'est pas c'est pas obligatoire c'est
pas obligatoire donc déjà on pourra
juste dire aux gens où sont fabriqués
vos produits comme ça les gens ils
peuvent acheter en connaissance de cause
la deuxième mesure c'est ce qu'a fait
Joe Biden dans jobiden il dit moi je
vais te donner de l'argent 6000 euros
7000 euros c'est ta voiture est
fabriquée
moi l'an dernier quand j'étais encore à
France stratégie on avait réfléchi à une
mesure qui disait aujourd'hui on donne
6000 euros quand tu achètes une voiture
électrique
d'où que viennois
quelle est la conséquence mais quand tu
achètes 50.000 voitures dont la batterie
fabriquée en Chine concrètement tu files
300 millions d'euros à la Chine pour
qu'elle devienne numéro 1 des voitures
électriques elle a pas forcément besoin
de tes 300 millions d'euros donc une
mesure qu'on pourra mettre en place
c'est de dire parce que ce qui compte
dans un objet l'empreinte carbone qui
est importante c'est pas la empreinte
carbone du transport parce que le
transport quand vous mettez sur un cargo
qui emporte des centaines de milliers de
tonnes ramenés aux produits c'est pas
grand chose c'est l'empreinte carbone de
la fabrication et donc de dire ben voilà
je vais te donner 6000 euros mais par
contre pas si ta batterie est fabriquée
au charbon donc je vais mettre une
limite une norme sur le contenu carbone
de la fabrication de la batterie
peut donner un chiffre ça va pas vous
avancer beaucoup mais ça pourrait être
quelque chose comme 50 kg de CO2 par
kilowattheure si tu utilises plus de CO2
pour fabriquer ta batterie tu as pas le
droit à ce truc là tu as pas le droit
aussi 1000 euros et si c'est moi qui a
le droit on pourrait aller plus loin
demain s'il y a pas d'énergie fossile
pour fabriquer ta batterie si c'est que
l'électricité tient droit et donc ça
forcément la France avec l'électricité
une des électricités les plus
décarbonées au monde avec son nucléaire
mais aussi avec son hydraulique et bien
nous allions avoir un avantage
compétitif et nous allions subventionner
les voitures fabriquées en France en
restant compatible avec les règles de
l'OMC parce que nous on essaie de les
respecter a priori et notamment on a le
droit de mettre ce genre de mesure quand
ça concerne l'environnement après c'est
que des c'est que des la fiscalité la
sexualité c'est c'est la dernière
prérogative qui reste des États membres
donc on peut faire à peu près ce qu'on
veut avec la fiscalité
bon il faut annoncer les choses
directement
on achète que français dès qu'on peut
acheter français
dès que c'est bleu blanc rouge on achète
et on fait du protectionnisme
on peut rajouter un truc moi je
rajouterais un on achète d'occas et
français du coup tu as raison parce que
le d'occasion sur pas mal de sites
maintenant ça peut arriver d'un peu
partout et là tu as un coup de transport
réel parce que il y a des camions qui
sillonnent l'Europe avec je vais pas
citer des sites mais voilà il peut y
avoir beaucoup de multiplication de
petits colis liés à l'e-commerce y
compris des e-commerce de seconde main
mais oui d'accord d'occasion ensuite
français si on peut c'est pas toujours
facile surtout mais très important parce
qu'en fait le problème de d'acheter
français c'est que c'est que ça coûte
plus cher en fait auparavant on avait
des coûts sociaux je vous fais juste un
exemple
ouais non mais j'avais presque fini du
coup non non mais évidemment qu'il faut
il faut il faut essayer de faire ça
enfin encore une fois je pense qu'on
on peut s'en
la crise sanitaire a montré qu'il
pouvait y avoir des évolutions assez
intéressantes quand même à la fois dans
notre manière de percevoir le chaud les
choses et puis globalement je pense
qu'on a même pas fini de tirer les
leçons de la crise il y a des Pays-Bas
quand on disait tout à l'heure la crise
elle est encore là et pauvres ils sont
ils sont assez affreusement confinés
donc dans les modes de consommation il
va y avoir des choses mais tout à
l'heure tu disais par exemple le
transport c'est très très peu c'est vrai
quand c'est du transport par bateau mais
par le frais aérien explose pendant
qu'on a tous nos petits jeunes qui sont
là en mode flixcam oh là là est-ce que
je prends l'avion et j'ose plus je sais
pas quoi bon très bien c'est pourquoi
pas le fret aérien c'est jamais aussi
bien porté les commandes d'avion qui
évidemment seront pas des avions
hydrogène parce que voilà et même ils
seront encore en train de voler en 2045
ceux qui vont sortir de l'usine
maintenant c'est bourré de trucs c'est
des fringues c'est parce que la fast
fashion est réclame ça c'est des
produits électroniques c'est enfin c'est
c'est hallucinant donc on se rend pas
compte finalement de
il y a une pointe de l'iceberg qui est
finalement notre vie la manière dont on
chauffe dans on se déplace dans mais il
y a aussi tout ce qu'on mobilise autour
de nous tous les objets qui sont
effectivement provoqués par nos actes de
consommation une fine alors parce qu'on
n'a pas forcément le choix je suis
d'accord mais
vous connaissez
ouais de loin enfin moi j'ai jamais
déjeuné avec elle mais
c'est qui Elizabeth borne Elisabeth
borne a le seul
rapport direct par rapport mais contact
que j'ai eu avec Isabelle borde quand
j'étais à France stratégie
donc on a proposé en juin 2019 donc tu
connais Isabelle tu continues
mais je la connais pas non j'ai jamais
eu de contact avec
le contact avec le cabinet
donc c'est intéressant donc en fait on a
publié une étude diffamation pas de déni
une étude
stratégie où on
proposait de mettre un bonus malus sur
le poids des voitures pour avoir des
voitures plus petites voitures plus
légère
et donc et donc il y a des députés qui
ont proposé des amendements qui ont été
repris comme Matthieu Orphelin par
exemple et donc c'est arrivé sur le
bureau des diabète borne c'est c'est ses
amendements pour mettre en place ce
bonus malus et elle s'est dit mais c'est
quoi cette histoire qui m'a pondu cette
idée donc elle a demandé au ministère à
la DGEC qui font généralement ce genre
de proposition mais qui ils ont pas fait
ça ils ont dit mais non c'est pas ça
c'est France stratégie
et donc la veille de l'examen de la loi
à l'Assemblée son cabinet m'a demandé de
venir pour leur expliquer la mesure et
pourquoi il fallait mettre ça en place
et le jour même de l'examen elle a dit
écoutez France stratégie d'habitude ils
font des choses assez intéressantes mais
là franchement je comprends pas ils ont
pété un câble donc non pour nous le
poids c'est proportionnel aux émissions
de CO2 donc on a déjà un bonus là-dessus
ça nous intéresse pas il faut expliquer
en détail pourquoi bah il faut expliquer
en détail pourquoi en fait il faut
expliquer en gros pour faire simple les
voitures aujourd'hui elles consomment de
l'essence elle compense du diesel et ça
peut avoir un équivalent en émission de
CO2 et ça on est une réglementation
européenne où il faut limiter les les
émissions de CO2 donc on regarde est-ce
que les émissions de CO2 diminue
sauf que depuis 20 ans en fait qu'est-ce
que fait l'industrie automobile elle
fait baisser les émissions de CO2
sur le banc dans les laboratoires mais
pas dans la vraie vie d'accord en fait
sur les vraie vie c'est comme sur le
pont
pour la simple et bonne raison qu'en
fait les cycles les cycles vous avez un
cycle européen qui s'appelle en anglais
new driving qui était le cycle qui
marchait jusqu'en 2020 qui a été mis en
place dans les années 60 et le but était
pas de mesurer des émissions de CO2
parce qu'à l'époque on en parlait pas du
CO2 c'était de homogénéiser les
procédures d'homologation entre les
différents pays européens donc ça
représentait très très mal la
consommation de la voiture donc on a mis
en place des choses comme un Stop and
Start qui font beaucoup de gains sur ce
cycle virtuel qui n'existe pas et donc
deux tiers de la baisse constatait des
émissions de CO2 depuis 2000 sont
factices
et donc nous ce qu'on propose c'est de
se dire bah moi quand je monte sur ma
balance le matin je peux pas tricher
voilà si je me suis fait un gros golden
non j'ai du mal à tricher je peux
essayer de me tenir avec avec la
commande à côté mais donc c'est de se
dire on va prendre un thermomètre qui
est plus fiable quel poids la voiture et
le poids ça tombe bien parce qu'il va
être proportionnelle à sa consommation à
son empreinte en matériau avec un
certain nombre de facteurs et donc c'est
le plus facile et on pourra plus tricher
parce que c'est ce qu'on a fait depuis
20 ans
mais ça ça n'a pas intéressé Isabelle
borne ce qui est dommage c'est que cette
mesure elle nous permet de baisser la
consommation de carburant accessoirement
comme en Europe un tiers notre
consommation de carburant vient de
Russie on aurait pu faire baisser notre
consommation de pétrole russe
et ça c'est une mesure finalement qui a
été prise un peu contrainte et forcée
par Emmanuel Macron après la convention
citoyenne ou finalement aujourd'hui vous
avez effectivement un malus sur le des
voitures de plus d'une tonne 8 qui va
concerner à peu près 50 000 SUV allemand
puisque nous en France on en produit
aucune nous de plus d'une tenue
on produit aucune voiture qui fait payer
en France donc nous ce qu'on proposait
c'est de dire
au niveau européen pas au niveau de la
France on met en place comme on a cette
règle 95 g de CO2 par kilomètre que
doivent respecter les constructeurs on
va mettre un poids que doivent respecter
les constructeurs une tonne 3 si tu
vends des voitures on fait la moyenne à
la fin de l'année que ça fait plus d'une
tonne 3 tu fais un chèque si tu vends
des voitures et qu'elle fait moins d'une
tonne 3 mais tu récupères un chèque de
celui qui vend des voitures plus lourdes
et donc ça ça permettait notamment de
rééquilibrer les marges entre les
voitures puisque le plus la voiture est
lourde plus le constructeur gagne de
l'argent et donc ça permettait d'inciter
les constructeurs à faire des voitures
plus légères parce que depuis 10 ans
qu'est-ce que font les constructeurs ils
arrêtent de fabriquer des voitures
légères parce qu'il gagne pas d'argent
et ils vendent des voitures de plus en
plus lourdes mais en gros pour faire
simple ce système revenait à ce que les
constructeurs allemands ça c'est un
chèque constructeur français sachant que
la Commission européenne est dirigée
grosso modo par les Allemands c'est
quelque chose qui n'arrivera pas j'ai
que par les Allemands elle est
influencée très comportement par les
Allemands
alors ça c'est des sources assez haute
couleur que vous entendez à Paris
avec Karima délicarima délice c'est une
députée
européenne qui est
je dis pas de bêtises président de la
Commission de transport du Parlement
européen et elle a voulu mettre en place
une
discussion en petit groupe avec les
principales parties prenantes comment
dire niveau européen sur l'automobile
donc les ONG organisent organisation non
gouvernementales les constructeurs
automobiles les équipementsiers pour
discuter d'une feuille de route à
horizon 2030 pour transformer
l'industrie automobile européenne et la
réconcilier entre guillemets avec le
climat c'est à dire que le climat il
faut qu'on baisse les émissions de CO2
et l'industrie automobile pour qu'elle
gagne de l'argent il faut que les
augmente comment on fait et donc on a
voulu faire des réunions plusieurs
réunions et vous ayez qui à cette
réunion vous avez le lobby s’en chef de
BMW le lobbyiste en chef de Mercedes le
lobby 600 chef de Volkswagen il est pas
des constructeurs français
alpine il y avait une stagiaire de chez
Renault je crois et on a proposé à
Carlos Tavares qui était très ouvert sur
ces discussions on a une femme de
recevoir donc il y avait pas les
constructeurs français en fait les
constructeurs français ne sont pas
intéressés par ce qui se passe au niveau
européen ils ont pas compris que tout se
joue et donc c'est les au-delà de ça le
métier du lobbyiste et un métier
profondément anglo-saxon nous je dis
souvent dans nos pays latins le lobby
c'est d'aller se prendre une bière après
la réunion une saper sur l'épaule en
fait c'est pas ça c'est des gens qui
sont payés à plein temps à Bruxelles
pour aller voir les gens de la
commission les parlementaires etc et non
c'est pas faire donc ma question sur
Elisabeth borne Elisabeth borne déclare
aujourd'hui nous dépendons du ciel
en faisant référence à la crise
énergétique
quand on entend le ce type de phrase
genre faut faire faut faire sa prière
ça vous intime de la confiance de la
capacité d'anticiper et donc de
gouverner ça vous intime des capacités
de résilience ça vous inspire qu'est-ce
que ça vous procure quand vous entendez
ça de l'immense joie
j'ai pas entendu la dans quel contexte
la phrase a été a été prononcée donc je
vais pas être trop fort mais ce que je
voulais dire sur Isabelle vente c'est
que
quelque chose qu'on peut dire c'est que
c'est elle a fait une école ingénieur et
de formation technique contrairement à
un certain nombre de prédécesseurs ou de
collègues donc c'est quelqu'un qui
normalement doit pas se faire embarquer
bêtement sur des questions techniques
elle est en capacité de juger à cet
ordre de choses je pense par exemple à
l'hydrogène de dire que ben voilà faut
pas faire des voitures électrogène c'est
complètement stupide parce que on perd
des trois quarts entre les deux tiers et
les trois quarts de l'électricité qu'il
a fallu pour passer par l'hydrogène avec
un électrolyseur puis pour stocker puis
pour repasser dans une pile à
combustible et pour à la finir le moteur
électrique donc hydrogène doit être
réservée à l'industrie par exemple
justement l'industrie des engrais
peut-être l'industrie de l'acier
peut-être des objets très lourds j'en
sais rien peut-être des camions des
avions etc mais sûrement pas des
bagnoles donc quand on est en train de
les anciens ministres par exemple qui
rejoignent des belles trucs de voitures
de luxe à hydrogène on devrait se
devrait elle être capable de monter au
créneau sur les choses comme ça bon
après c'est pas mal d'en remettre un peu
de spiritualité
dans tout ça ah ouais pas de blague mais
non mais
je me lance sur la page franchi un cran
léger quand même parce que si je me
remets à l'époque des masques par
exemple c'était non non tu vois bien
c'est super non il y a pas de problème
d'ailleurs ça sert à rien on n'a pas de
stock mais en fait ça sert à rien et
puis à moi après dans non c'était hyper
important fallait remettre partout et je
sais pas quoi donc là il y a une espèce
de franchise je trouve pas
inintéressante c'est vrai qu'au pied du
mur c'est peut-être plus facile d'être
franc bon ben voilà ouais on est un peu
on est un peu mal mais en même temps
moi le délestin je me fais pas si peur
que ça va d'abord
française ici alors ne laisse pas c'est
ça
on fait un petit blackout de deux heures
histoire de faire passer la pilule pour
soulager le réseau mais on déleste
d'accord il faut appeler un chat on est
quand même en France puissance nucléaire
on n'a pas d'idée mais non on n'a pas de
pétrole mais on a des idées
pas la langue française
si tu veux faire de la provoc ici tu dis
nous rentrons dans une croissance
négative
tout de suite on s'énerve alors vas-y
pas trop la pas trop de problèmes en
2050 on pourrait avoir des alors appelle
le blackout ou délestage comme tu veux
organiser accepter
et qu'on aurait prévu à l'avance
j'entends par là en fait tu coupes la
lumière quand tu sors de la chambre
alors non c'est de dire tu éteins le
wifi tu n'utilise qu'une seule plaque
électrique sur 4 alors ça c'est éteindre
le wifi c'était cet été c'était Olivier
Véran on était parti très loin donc ils
sont quand même formés pendant l'été sur
la sobriété parce que fallait éteindre
la box wifi avant de partir en vacances
c'était quand même ça le truc donc
effectivement c'est très utile indétains
de la box wifi il était c'est moins
utile divers si votre chauffage est
régulé électrique parce que finalement
la chaleur fatale de votre box wifi va
contribuer de manière très marginale à
chauffer la pièce dans laquelle il est
donc limite si vous poursuivez vos
enfants il faut les poursuivre en été
quand ils jouent à la Playstation et pas
en hiver en hiver il chauffe la part en
même temps quoi d'accord mais
donc on est parti très loin mais en 2050
en 2050 on sait qu'on va avoir un mix
d'énergie renouvelable bien plus
important qu'aujourd'hui d'accord quoi
qu'il arrive on suppute on suppute on
projette on projette on souhaite c'est
un
voilà on se on projette une trajectoire
qui est plus sympathique d'un point
d'interrogation
incantatoires ah non c'est plus que ça
c'est des scénarios qui sont bossés etc
bon alors après voilà il y a des trucs
sur sur les les effets l'efficience
énergétique des véhicules et tout qui
sont sans doute pas du tout à niveau
dans le dans ces trucs là mais on va
dire quand même globalement on a un mix
électrique qui sera de toute manière
avec ou sans nucléaire qu'on relance ou
pas du nucléaire il y aura beaucoup plus
d'énergie renouvelables tout simplement
parce que soit on aura pu être dispo le
pétrole le gaz soit on aura passé le pic
soit il sera trop cher donc on en aura
plus
on pourrait faire du beaucoup de solaire
le solaire c'est sympa on peut en faire
même sur les toits sur les entrepôts sur
les parkings etc le solaire c'est
vachement plus efficace que le vent par
rapport à la concentration qu'on a par
mètre carré sur terre juste pour donner
un ordre de grandeur quand tu reçois 100
watts de solaire tu reçois un des liens
d'accord c'est un c'est 100 fois moins
concentré en fait l'éolien que le que le
soleil coûte pas moins cher
énergétiquement parlant alors il peut y
avoir des histoires de coups mais
surtout il y a des histoires de
complémentarité c'est que du coup tu as
besoin de jouer sur le foisonnement pour
avoir à la fois de l'éolien à la fois du
solaire c'est bien parce que des fois
bah ouais la nuit l'hiver quand il y a
un peu moins de ou pas du tout de de
solaire tu peux compter sur l'éolien et
donc tu foisonnes avec un certain nombre
de un mix de renouvelables mais en tout
cas le mix de renouvelable il sera plus
important pourquoi je dis ça parce que
dans les scénarios de type RTE par
exemple on se retrouve avec de l'ordre
de 30 à 50% selon les scénarios des
hauts liens
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
pendant une semaine 10 jours en Europe
il faut encaisser en hiver il peut y
avoir pas de vent du tout sur toute
l'Europe ça arrive pas souvent mais ça
arrive
on verra parce que je sais pas
en tout cas ça peut arriver voilà et
donc dans ce cas-là si tu veux faire ton
boulot en version 2022 tu dis quoi qu'il
arrive j'appuie sur l'interrupteur et
donc il y a pas de vent j'ai 35 à 50% de
mon mix énergétique qui est pas là donc
faut que j'aille pomper dans des
dispositifs de stockage du coup
les mets sur les champs d'éoliens
tu peux avoir ça mais ça suffit sans
doute pas avec la avec la puissance
appelée
puissant quand même mais du coup
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que quand tu lis le rapport RT1 par
exemple ce qu'il faut mettre en face en
termes de dispositif de stockage que ça
soit des batteries des stations de
pompage turbinage des électrolyseurs où
tu vas perdre des trois quarts de ton
énergie électrique au passage etc etc
c'est gigantesque
or tu auras une autre solution c'est de
dire du soleil l'autre solution c'est
pas ça c'est de dire bah en fait on
pourrait accepter collectivement
qu'effectivement une fois de temps en
temps tous les deux trois ans quand il y
a pas de vent en Europe pendant 10 jours
bah ouais on va faire des blackout
organisés c'est à dire que on enverra
les électrons dans les hôpitaux on
enverra les électrons dans les
transports mais par contre on arrêtera
des trucs dans l'industrie on chauffera
un peu moins bah ouais ok et puis du
coup trois jours quatre jours cinq jours
sans vent me voilà à 15 degrés dans mon
appart ouais pas sympa mais ça économise
une quantité hallucinante de trucs à
déployer d'un point de vue industriel
alors qu'on va pas avoir le temps et la
capacité de déployer tout ça
énergétique ou est-ce que tu veux mettre
un anorak pour la faire de la
maintenance à 50 bornes de l'éolien au
fur tu vois c'est moi je préfère la Nora
chez moi tu vois c'est la je passe tu as
vu il y a une épidémie de grande flemme
là c'est c'est le c'est bifop qui a
sorti ça avec la Fondation Jean Jaurès
la grande flemme ils ont appelé ça c'est
les gens ont de moins en moins envie de
sortir de chez eux et ils sont sur leur
canapé ils se font livrer c'est des
conséquences entre autres de la crise
sanitaire
pas forcément parce qu'avec le beurre du
monde tu arrives toujours à trouver
quelqu'un que tu peux exploiter et que
moi c'est c'est malheureusement ça bon
donc il y a peut-être aussi le fait que
au boulot il y a moins de sens il y a
des gens qui trouvent je sais pas
peut-être qu'ils sont développeurs
metaves tu vois et qu'ils ont pas qui
qui trouvent pas de 25 à leur boulot
j'en sais rien en rentrant de soi
mais voilà on pourrait très bien
réfléchir à ça c'est-à-dire est-ce qu'on
paye une électricité qui sera plus cher
de fait beaucoup plus cher parce que le
renouvelable il est quand même plus cher
que ce qu'on a pu connaître pendant
l'étrangereuses le nucléaire il sera
plus cher aussi parce que il sera plus
sécurisé etc plein de choses est-ce
qu'on peut on veut payer en plus une
couche de stockage et de capacité à
avoir toujours la puissance appelée
nécessaire ou est-ce qu'on accepte une
sorte de dégradation mais pensées
systémique organisées ou temps en temps
bah ouais tant pis on n'en sera pas les
machines à laver cette semaine comment
tu as formulé ça on accepte une
dégradation je sais pas un peu comme les
trains en France les métros ah non alors
non on n'est pas on en est pas à pas
faire tourner les trains non les trains
on est en train d'accepter une
dégradation
je suis pas sûr là pour moi c'est plutôt
le contraire alors je vais pas faire
corporate parce que sinon je me fais
engueuler en rentrant à la maison donc
mais non non je pense que le non non je
pense que l'exigence
l'exigence des consommateurs date sur
les transports par exemple et en
particulier sur le train et devenu
impressionnant c'est à dire que tu es
dans un truc un peu incroyable qui fait
du 300 km/h qui te fait du point à point
dans les distances de dingue en deux
heures 40 je sais pas quoi et si le truc
il a 6 minutes de retard et que il est
arrêté en pleine voix pendant une minute
trente et que t'as pas l'info du
contrôleur tu te fais engueuler sur
Twitter enfin c'est quand même
aujourd'hui c'est ça les consommateurs
que nous sommes partis je les
producteurs que nous sommes aussi tu
vois le TGV sur par exemple le métro
le métro c'est des manques de conducteur
c'est en fait c'est un problème humain
en fait on a un problème humain de les
bus
l'énergie là
il y a moins de métro parce que on
économie
et donc si des coups de l'énergie
continue d'augmenter comme ça est-ce
qu'il faut s'attendre à ce que nos
métros peuvent TGV nos métros soit de
moins en moins agréable moins rapide de
plus en plus surdoué est-ce qu'il faut
pas regarder les sociétés
tiers mondialisées
pour savoir à quels sont vêtements
regardez l'Inde
vous avez déjà pris des trains en Inde
tu as déjà pris un train en Inde c'est
extraordinaire c'est un wagon français
qui date de 1958
dans son jus et des fois vous avez 30
heures de retard sur un trajet qui on
faisait 20 je vous conseille d'ailleurs
l'Imodium par boîte de 12 ça vous sauve
un trajet en train et puis visez tout de
suite la première classe parce que
oubliez la seconde et la troisième non
mais tu peux regarder une société
[Musique]
Madagascar
ont recycle on fait de la troisième
quatrième cinquième main
est-ce qu'il faudrait pas habituer nous
nos entreprises à faire les week-ends
à Madagascar qui leur explique un petit
peu ce que c'est accepter une
dégradation
est-ce qu'il faut l'accepter cette
dégradation où il faut peut-être un
petit peu sagitté pour reprendre la
passivité intellectuelle le manque de
prêt de prévision de prévoyance de nos
dirigeants de nos ingénieurs
est-ce qu'il faut peut-être un petit peu
s'énerver les gars là c'est pas que
c'est pas que du manque de prévoyance tu
vois parce que
comme des fleurs
ah bah on est dépendant des matières
premières d'où est-ce que ça vient ah on
est dépendre ce type de pays
alors ça fait combien de temps qu'on
parle d'énergie en sens à faire 10 ans
notre première vidéo là où je me foutais
de toi
2015 effectivement de mettre un pull ça
fait combien de temps qu'on parle
d'énergie ensemble au moins 15 ans
donc il y a un défaut d'anticipation des
gestion et là on les voit tous s'agiter
mais pas pas encore une fois pas avec
les sans doute pas avec des solutions
qui sont les bonnes parce que finalement
c'est c'est effectivement ce n'est
qu'une dégradation alors on peut aller
plus loin que le train en Inde si tu
veux prendre le vrai standard parce que
un train c'est un truc compliqué en fait
c'est un réseau entretenir mais en moins
tu l'entretiens que tu baisses la
vitesse c'est le seul système donc c'est
un manière très efficace de baisser les
coudes maintenant ça mais évidemment tu
vas moins vite mais il y a plein de pays
où il y a juste pas de train tout court
tu as juste des bus et le bus
alors non il y a des trains il y a pas
mal de train de fret aux États-Unis il y
a pas mal de côtes côte ouest côte est
et puis tu as aussi quand même sur la
côte est à quelques trucs mais c'est
vrai que
sans doute plus proche de l'Inde que de
la France c'est pas non j'exagère un peu
non mais c'est pas le Japon quoi en tout
cas voilà en terme de standard mais non
mais je pensais plutôt par l'Amérique du
Sud ouais c'est des bus parce que le bus
qu'est-ce qui peut il peut encaisser un
nid de poule il peut être en panne puis
l'autre par quand même alors que un
train c'était un train en panne le train
derrière il passera pas forcément c'est
un transport guidé hein donc c'est le
but et tu peux même aller plus loin
évidemment c'est le bus qui part quand
il est plein parce que évidemment tu
optimises l'énergie comme ça et même tu
peux même même des gens accrocher sur le
bord des portières tu vois quand tu es
dans le minibus avec Kinshasa donc tu as
tous les modes possibles évidemment donc
Kinshasa l'idée est pas d'aller jusque
là en fait parce que ça c'est de la
dégradation
ça c'est évidemment c'est de la vraie
dégradation subit forte méchante
désagréable donc effectivement en fait
tu peux te dire si on s'inspirait des
bidouilleurs géniaux en Afrique ou à
Madagascar effectivement qui sont
capables de bosser sur l'électronique
sur des moteurs de réparer des trucs
voilà ça te rend quelque part plus
résilient ça te rend plus souvent parce
que bah oui tu n'attends pas ton vélo
neuf parce que le précédent tu sais pas
le bricoler réparer t'attends pas ta
carte électronique pour réparer ta
chaudière qui te dit allume toi
éteins-toi tu as un mec avec un testeur
un machin à faire à souder qui est
capable de changer un truc et voilà
c'est ça aussi la résidence donc
effectivement aller vers un monde de la
de la réparation d'entretien c'est c'est
une manière de résister à des chocs
futures qui viendront je sais pas si ça
sera sanitaire ça sera géopolitique ça
sera ressource ça sera autre chose vous
avez une chaudière au fioul alors moi
j'ai je suis en maison de ville et j'ai
une chaudière à gaz
qui m'énerve parce que j'ai changé la
carte électronique intégralement un pavé
de 20 cm par 20 cm je confirme pour un
truc qu'elle est pas dedans personne
n'est capable de me dire quoi ça me
coûtera une fortune évidemment de savoir
mais je l'ai à la maison s'il y a
quelqu'un qui veut je peux vous
l'envoyer en ce moment c'est pénurie
pour en avoir d'ailleurs
du coup peut-être que voilà du coup
peut-être que je pourrais revendre je
pourrais revendre de casse peut-être ma
plaque électronique oui je voulais dire
après une autre un autre type de de
sobriété possible et c'est c'est par
exemple le fait de dire que aujourd'hui
on est en train de de continuer alors
parce qu'on est dans un modèle de
compétition mondiale avec des métropoles
qui doivent être puissantes qui sont
créatrices d'emploi c'est là que ça se
passe voilà la créative classe le
numérique les start-up et tout c'est
génial donc on met trop police voilà
alors les grandes villes elles ont
toujours attirées je veux dire il y
avait des porteurs d'eau auvergnat au
18e siècle et puis les les jeunes
bretonnes venaient faire nourrissent
c'était un peu genre
malheureusement mais c'est comme ça mais
on a exacerbé finalement cette ce
phénomène de concentration en disant
c'est bien les villes les villes
concentrées les grandes métropoles elles
sont on utilise plus les transports en
commun donc elles sont plus écolos et
puis en plus c'est là que ça crée de
l'emploi ça crée de la richesse du PIB
c'est super résultat de ça si tu ajoutes
avec la décohabitation c'est-à-dire le
fait qu'on est de moins en moins
nombreux parfois foyer en fait ça c'est
lié au vieillissement de la population
c'est lié éventuellement divorce lié aux
enfants qui vont faire des études
parcoursup les envois d'un bout à
l'autre de la évidemment de la France et
bien tout ça ça fait que aujourd'hui
quand on a un habitant de plus en France
on met deux logements en chantier et on
se plaint et donc tu crées du vacant en
fait donc tu il y a à peu près entre
150000 et 200 000 personnes de plus par
an le résultat du solde démographique
etc et donc pour ça faut mettre 350 000
logements à chantier et 350 000
logements en chantier 250 000 résidences
principales 50 000 résidences de
tourisme ou résidences secondaires des
petits app dans les Landes et je sais
pas quoi 50 000 vacances ça c'est ce
qu'on a fait les 10 dernières années
donc on vide des trucs on construit des
trucs avec du ciment et de l'acier pour
vider d'autres trucs ailleurs il y a
déjà des logements qui sont préoccupés
en France la 3 millions qui sont vacants
dont
2 millions qu'on appelle plutôt de la
vacance frictionnelle c'est-à-dire que
c'est moins de 2 ans et en fait c'est
plutôt les héritages le temps de faire
des travaux des ventes etc et puis il y
a un million qui est vacants depuis plus
de 2 ans effectivement et celui-là on a
du mal à investir parce que c'est des
maisons qui sont pas bien isolées qui
sont au centre-ville de petites villes
avec la route départementale et 38
tonnes qui passent devant et donc bah
non tout le monde veut plutôt un
pavillon avec la petite piscine au fond
je sais pas quoi pour faire jouer les
enfants donc il y a un peu tout ça mais
on pourrait aller donc il y a ça il y a
des résidences secondaires il y a 3,6
millions aujourd'hui alors c'est c'est
aussi des tout petits apparts donc on va
pas tous installer à l'Alpe d'Huez
on s'arrête un peu compliqué et puis pas
forcément très sympa mais du coup il y a
quand même quelques centaines de sans
doute de logement qui pourraient être
récupéré comme résidence principale en
particulier sur les littoraux ou les
gens arrivent plus à se loger parce
qu'il y a trop de Airbnb et compagnie et
puis il y a la sous-occupation il y a 8
millions de logements aujourd'hui en
France qui sont sous occupés à
définition de l'Insee alors ça veut dire
quoi sous occuper ben voilà quand vous
avez les moyens vous avez tout seul dans
200m², voilà c'est sous occupé je prends
un exemple un peu extrême volontairement
mais voilà ça il y a des définitions un
peu complexes qui dépendent de l'âge des
enfants parce qu'ils construit son petit
ils peuvent être dans la même pièce et
en temps et puis après on considère que
c'est bien qu'ils aient leur chambre
chacun etc bref je sais il y a aussi un
million et demi de logements qui sont
sur occupés donc il y a évidemment le
mal logement à mettre en face de ça mais
globalement
si on n'était pas dans cette machine à
métropoliser et bien on pourrait ne pas
construire ne plus construire un mètre
carré de de logement d'info en France
alors évidemment c'est des impacts
divers et variés économiques bien
entendu mais on pourrait consacrer du
coup à faire x 20 sur la réhabilitation
dont on parlait tout à l'heure et ça
qu'est-ce que ça permet ça peut
permettre de
revitaliser les bourses les villages les
villes moyennes les petites villes et
Ben et de faire aussi même de la
démobilité aujourd'hui pourquoi on a
besoin de voiture ce qu'il faut faire 40
bornes pour aller au boulot le matin à
40 bornes pour rentrer qu'il faut faire
30 minutes pour déposer la petite à
l'école de danse et au club de foot et
qu'il faut faire une heure de bagnole
pour aller voir un spécialiste quand on
est en campagne c'est ça quoi ou passer
un examen médical voilà et c'est ça la
réalité et ben demain et on pourrait
tout à fait imaginer un monde où il y a
encore de la mobilité mais qui soit pas
à cette espèce de mobilité pendulaire
hallucinante et qui évidemment est hyper
consommatrice d'énergie que ça soit
demain le vecteur électrique ou le
vecteur aujourd'hui de vecteurs
carburant et qui nous rend hyper
dépendant infini de tout ce bordel
autour de nous moi je suis pour une
coloc avec toi Philippe carrément alors
oui du coup tu as raison parmi deux
trucs pour réduire cette quantité de
sous-occupations il faut réinventer de
la coloc même intergénérationnelle tu
commences à avoir des choses comme ça tu
as des retraités avec des jeunes tu as
des couples que les enfants sont partis
faire des études ils accueillent des
étudiants tu as des gens qui font de la
densification douce qui découpent leur
grand pavillons de de leurs années 30 et
40 et je sais pas quoi et 50 et puis ils
disent maintenant je vais faire un petit
truc en bas et puis je vais pouvoir
accueillir un couple ou un étudiant
enfin donc il y a tout ça qui peut se
passer mais ce sont des leviers je
prends plus socio-technique qui est
implique des questions de de donner
envie à des gens de d'utiliser d'autres
modèles et comment généraliser toute
cette foultitude de petits exemples bien
sympa mais qui sont
presque anecdotiques aujourd'hui quoi
revenons à Elisabeth borne et
et c'est prière
aujourd'hui nous dépendons du ciel c'est
quand même magnifique
la France du 21e siècle extraordinaire
la prière je sais pas si ça sert à
grand-chose
pour que le soleil soit et luisant
c'est quoi un confinement énergétique
quand j'entends que pendant le covid
notre consommation énergétique a baissé
de 10%
et là ce qu'il faut faire c'est de
c'est simple
12%
on doit faire 12 pour pour réussir à
atteindre les objectifs
fixés par le gouvernement les 15% de
réduction sur le gaz c'est 12 donc c'est
tous les ans
c'est 12 non c'est 12 là la première
année on va pas faire 12 chaque année
mais juste 12 c'est Valérie on a fait on
a fait 1 à 2 par an c'est à peu près ça
leur demandeur ben voilà 10 on l'a fait
qu'on a été confiné pendant trois quatre
semaines qu'on a fermé tous les
commerçants essentiels qu'on a arrêté un
certain nombre de villes qu'on s'est
beaucoup moins déplacé donc qu'est-ce
que ça ça à quoi ça ressemble un conflit
de énergétique heureusement ça va pas
ressembler a priori à un monde où on
habite chez soi il faut faire une
attestation pour aller pisser c'est pas
ça
mais par contre ça ressemble
on entend des universités qui vont
fermer une semaine plus tôt avant Noël
qui vont ouvrir une semaine après plus
tard après Noël pour pouvoir ne pas
chauffer donc les gens ils voient tout
et moi de chez eux ça c'est quoi par
exemple c'est des entreprises qui vont
dire bah voilà on va mettre le
télétravail pour tout le monde le
vendredi comme ça on va pas chauffer
l'immeuble
le bureau mais sauf que les gens chez
eux ils vont tous se chauffer donc
vraisemblablement l'impact positif entre
guillemets ça va être à vérifier parce
qu'on va avoir un effet un peu de de
diffusion savoir ressembler à quoi le
confinement énergétique mais savoir
ressembler ce qu'on a vécu avec les
grèves de chez Total et des autres
raffineries en France on avait plus de
carburant vous avez plus de carburant
vous restez chez vous que plus vous
déplacez malheureusement des pénuries de
carburant et notamment de diesel où on a
une situation qui est assez tendue au
niveau mondial on a des stocks de diesel
qui sont plus bas aux États-Unis on a
décidé de se passer de notre principal
exportateur qui est la Russie qui nous
fournit beaucoup de diesel on a fermé un
certain nombre de raffineries en Europe
depuis une dizaine d'années diesel donc
qui fabrique du diesel aujourd'hui les
Indiens qui vont nous le revendre à base
de pétrole russe éventuellement les
Chinois et puis accessoirement peut-être
qu'on en aura pas le diesel c'est
l'énergie des industries c'est l'énergie
du transport pas de de sport de Monsieur
et Madame lambda entre guillemets mais
du transport des camions des bus des
bateaux
tractopelle des tractopelle donc vous
avez plus de diesel en fait vous êtes
économie s'arrête et ça c'est ça c'est
très préoccupant donc c'est chez vous
quoi ça s'appelle un confinement donc il
y a quand même beaucoup de
malheureusement beaucoup de scénarios si
on veut atteindre ces économies là ça va
être compliqué si on ferme des usines
les gens qui étaient qui travaillent à
l'usine où est-ce qu'ils se retrouvent
alors une petite touche de
d'optimisme où est-ce que le
gouvernement en fait ce qui s'est passé
ce qui nous arrive en Europe c'est déjà
arrivé à un pays il y a une trentaine
d'années
du jour au lendemain effectivement ils
se sont passés du jour au lendemain de
un tiers de leur approvisionnement de
pétrole il se trouve que c'était aussi
du pétrole Ruther et donc nous c'est ce
qu'on fait exactement un tiers on fait
pas des jours au lendemain comme eux
parce que le choc a été très très donc
comment est-ce qu'ils ont fait cubain
ils ont quand même un avantage par
rapport à là en tout cas la métropole
c'est qu'ils ont un peu de soleil et
quelques plages et ce qui se sont
déplacés en train non ils sont pas
déplacés en train d'ailleurs je suis pas
sûr qu'il y avait beaucoup de trains à
Cuba bon ils sont beaucoup des
industrialisés bien évidemment mais en
gros ils ont découvert le vélo
et donc ils ont fait ils ont apporté des
vélos de Chine et donc ils sont mis à
faire des vélos ils ont transformé des
gros semi-remorques en
pour pouvoir transporter les gens
j'invite ceux qui me suivent il y a un
documentaire qui s'appelle le pouvoir de
la communauté qui s'appelle en anglais
how Cuba sur vibes pick oil comment Cuba
a survécu au pétrolier ça fait 52
minutes et ça vous mettra un petit peu
de baume au coeur parce qu'on voit qu'en
fait face à cette contrainte ils ont mis
en place des solutions sur l'agriculture
ils avaient l'agriculture la plus
mécanisée d'Amérique donc y compris
Amérique du Nord-Amérique du Sud et donc
ils ont dû ils avaient plus de tracteurs
ils avaient plus de pièces de rechange
j'avais plus de dizaines donc ils ont
tout réduire réduit toutes les surfaces
ils ont développé le le potager
aujourd'hui vous avez 70% des fruits et
légumes qui sont consommés à La Havane
qui viennent de La Havane et donc pour
le coup du circu donc c'est les
champions du monde de la permaculture
autre chose on parle de covoiturage tout
à l'heure il me semble qu'ils ont rendu
alors obligatoire l'autostop donc si
vous prenez pas quelqu'un en auto top je
sais pas si c'est une amende ou si c'est
la prison mais en gros vous êtes
forcément incité à prendre vos collègues
et moi je suis allé avoir un ami à Cuba
en 2011 donc il y a plus de 10 ans et je
me balade à Varadero je vois que des
scooters électriques il se déplacent
tous en scooter électrique c'était assez
je me suis dit pourquoi est-ce que nous
on est encore avec nous vieux scooter
qui plus etc en fait il faut venir avec
de Chine les énormes bustes qui bourdent
de scooter électrique et donc ils sont
déjà passés ils sont déjà un peu un peu
en avance par rapport à nous sur ces
choses
ils ont eu un peu faim quand même un
moment parce que il manquait les engrais
aussi en fait les engrais étaient
produits en Russie la Russie est
toujours un grand producteur d'engrais
et d'ailleurs ça posait question et ça
pose encore un peu question aujourd'hui
évidemment et en plus avec le prix du
gaz qui a monté donc ils ont eu voilà et
donc il y a ces fameuses exemples très
très écolos et sympa ou ils sont mis à
planter des
légumineuse qui a enrichit en azote le
sol au milieu des rangs de maïs et en
plus comme ça se ça se récolte pas au
même moment ils arrivaient à combiner
des trucs donc ils ont inventé plein de
choses effectivement mais pour mais ils
ont inventé un peu le couteau dans le
dos quand même de ce point-là ou le
couteau sous la gorge ouais et non non
ils ont quand même eu faim mais et puis
l'autre aspect qui est la limite de la
métaphore mais cela dit elle peut tout à
fait tout à fait inspirant quand même
mais c'est que il y avait de le terrible
embargo et donc c'est pareil c'est
toujours non ouais alors que tu crois
très légèrement très légèrement amendé
enfin je sais pas enfin on réduit je
sais pas exactement mais oui et donc du
coup ça tu peux pas non plus importer ce
que tu veux d'où tu veux et donc tu
étais en plus il savait cette contrainte
là supplémentaire donc ça faisait
vraiment ça faisait vraiment beaucoup
nous on est voilà pas tout à fait dans
cette situation là
période est spéciale qui a été très dur
pendant 5 à 10 ans et qui aggravait la
ville et puis
on fait un scénario totalement
science-fiction
je discute avec mes cutéreux locaux on
s'appelle comme ça parce que on vit dans
la campagne on a des poules nous
les engrais compliqué le prix des
engrais là certains disent on va pas
planter parce que on va pas pouvoir
répercuter sur les prix
écouter avec d'autres ils nous disent si
on met pas d'engrais les sols ils sont
tellement dévastés depuis des années que
l'azote dedans compliqué on va peut-être
faire des cultures qui fixent un peu
l'azote est-ce qu'en France il faut
s'attendre à
un petit coup de frein sur
l'accessibilité à la nourriture pas trop
trop cher
est-ce que vous comprenez ma question si
le choc énergétique s'accentue est-ce
qu'on va vraiment le sentir sur les
questions alimentaires l'aliment est une
calorie
je pense une calorie assimilée pour 9
calories fossiles
je tente mais je pense que ça le
rendrait une analyse vachement plus
poussée donc là on y va
je suis pas sûr de pouvoir l'amener en
direct mais d'abord la première chose
c'est que dans le prix du pain il n'y a
pas que le prix du blé
il y a le prix du boulanger et plein
d'autres gens et du gaz du four et toute
la série d'intermédiaires et du stockage
etc donc quand tu ça finalement un peu
comme sur l'essence quand le prix du
pétrole double l'essence double pas là
c'est pour les taxes quand le prix du
blé double le pain double pas on peut
essayer de le faire croire parce que on
essaie de passer de 5 centimes
d'augmentation je sais pas quoi mais ça
c'est il y a quand même un effet
absorbant de tout le reste de la chaîne
bon absorbant jusqu'à quand je sais pas
parce qu'il y a aussi une inflation des
salaires il y a aussi une inflation de
toute la chaîne est en train de monter
donc effectivement il y a ce sujet là
mais quand même il y a un petit peu un
coussin potentiel ensuite deuxième sujet
c'est qu'effectivement les les
agriculteurs ils arbitres entre à
combien ils espèrent vendre sur le
marché mondial
parce que il y a quand même ce sujet là
c'est qu'à un moment c'est les exports
qui restent une petite partie qui fixe
qui qui donne le la finalement de du
prix auquel tout le monde achète donc
c'est un peu comme le dernier
kilowattheure en électricité avec le
prix du gaz on a un peu un quelque part
même s'il y a des achats industriels de
plus structurés mais globalement il y a
quand même un peu ça aussi dans
l'agriculture et donc on est ils ont on
est très exposés parce qu'on est on est
on est exportateur donc il y a un
arbitrage qui se fait dire c'est plus je
mets d'engrais plus j'ai un rendement
élevé et donc en fonction du prix auquel
je peux vendre des prix auquel je paye
l'engrais je peux effectivement mettre
un peu moins d'engrais et avoir un
rendement un peu moins élevé c'est pas
complètement mécanique sa plafonne au
bout d'un moment
le rendement mais il y a quand même un
peu cette idée là donc oui ça va créer
des phénomènes d'arbitrage d'ailleurs on
envoie pas sur les grandes cultures pour
le coup mais pas sur sur les légumes et
des gens qui vont pas faire pousser des
tomates sous serre cet hiver parce que
parce que le c'est trop cher quoi donc
les serres chauffés c'est ce sont des
des grands émetteurs de de CO2 en France
si vous regardez ils ont échappé je
crois de peu aux émissions de au trading
des missions de CO2 mais ils étaient pas
passé loin parce que ça pouvait être
déséquivalent de raffinerie ou de trucs
chimiques pas chaque site mais voilà
donc voilà on va échapper à cette tomate
là est-ce que c'est un mâle bah oui pour
les gens qui vivent de ça aujourd'hui et
qu'on fait les investissements donc
c'est le problème de la destru de la
destruction créatrice ou peterienne quoi
comment on accompagne ces gens comment
on les laisse pas sur le carreau comment
on arrive à repasser sur autre chose
mais finalement voilà c'est c'est une
espèce de flux débile avec les moi j'en
ai transporté dans ma dans ma carrière
des tomates hollandaises qui
descendaient en Italie et tomate
italienne qui montait en Hollande le
secret c'est que c'est pas les mêmes
tomates c'est tomate bio gorgées de
soleil qui montaient pour les Hollandais
riches et puis les tomates hollandaises
pas bonnes qui descendaient pour les
Italiens pauvres mais voilà c'est c'est
quand même assez flou là donc voilà ça
va forcément calmer un peu ça quand
l'énergie monte bah voilà il y aura
moins il y aura moins de trucs
bon alors sur les grandes cultures moi
je pense que voilà je pense que il y a
des des effets quand même
amortisseurs et voilà je pense pas qu'on
se retrouve à avoir faim et puis encore
une fois c'est là qu'on revient sur la
question sobriété bah
à peu près je sais pas 90% si je compte
les peintures et ce qui passe en maïs
pour les animaux doit avoir 90% des
surfaces agricoles en France qui est
consacrée aux protéines animales
donc après il y a pas mal d'apports
d'export on passe tout ça mais voilà
c'est quand même un peu l'idée donc
baisser un peu éventuellement les
rendements baisser un peu la quantité
d'engrais et puis
augmenter un peu les prix et puis se
dire que la viande et ben oui elle est
quand même un peu plus cher et puis que
passer
une certaine quantité j'en sais rien de
trois fois par semaine bah voilà
peut-être on en mange un peu moins
pourquoi pas quoi le problème c'est
toujours une question
faut dire référence
à des bonnets rouges et des gilets
jaunes dans le rétroviseur est-ce que
vous attendez à des troubles sociaux
conséquents dans les mois ou l'année à
venir
à cause de du choc énergétique pour le
coup je vais vas-y commence
de Philippe sur la nourriture parce que
quand on regarde le salaire réel des
gens en Europe le salaire réel c'est
votre salaire moins l'inflation c'est
10% de moins 10% de moins alors il y a
l'inflation sur les coûts de l'énergie
le carburant entre guillemets c'est pour
l'instant ça a été un peu contrôlé on a
quand même à des niveaux et encore là on
est quand même des niveaux qui sont
beaucoup plus élevés que lors des gilets
jaunes on a 50 centimes de plus parler
quasiment on est à 2,20 ou un truc comme
ça
vous avez tous les coups de la
nourriture je crois que c'est
[Musique]
Monsieur Leclerc qui disait Edward
Leclerc qui disait Michel Édouard
qui disait plus 10 à 20% sur les coudes
de la nourriture eux c'est la première
fois dans le métier de la grande
distribution c'est de tailler les
croupirs alors fournisseur ils ont
jamais vu là ça fait deux ou trois fois
qu'ils sont en train de mettre des
augmentations de prix parce que sinon
les gens ne peuvent pas tenir ça ne
s'est jamais vu dans la grande
distribution il existe quelques dizaine
d'années j'imagine et donc moi je suis
pas très
je suis un peu perplexe alors j'ai fait
une table ronde il y a quelques semaines
avec
Priscilla ludovski je paye quand chez
son nom mais qui était la première gilet
jaune qui avait fait la pétition sur les
prix du carburant etc et j'ai dit mais
où est-ce qu'ils sont passés parce qu'en
fait les conditions on a l'inflation les
prix des caméras sont beaucoup plus
élevés est-ce qu'ils ont été drogués à
l'argent magique où sont passés les
gilets jaunes
et elle m'a dit bah en fait
ils ont fait leur part
ils ont passé beaucoup de temps ils ont
fait taper sur la gueule certains y ont
laissé les yeux des mains et des trucs
comme ça donc
la priori je suis pas sûr qu'on va ré
avoir un mouvement à ce niveau là moi
j'ai une phrase que j'ai en tête je sais
plus qui est ici mais qui qui que la
différence entre la paix et la guerre
civile c'est trois repas par jour un
truc comme ça donc si les gens doivent
commencer à serrer la ceinture à prendre
un deux repas par jour un repas par jour
on va commencer ici peuvent plus
chauffer chez eux et qui se cachent chez
eux peut-être qu'ils auront envie
d'aller sur un rond-point se faire un
barbec et voilà et se retrouver donc
c'est compliqué
un complément quand même parce que moi
je pense que je comprends ce que tu ce
que tu dis et l'histoire de
l'augmentation des prix oui oui
en fait il y a pas que la question
énergétique dans tout ça c'est-à-dire
que si le prix d'énergie n'avait pas
explosé
on aurait quand même l'inflation est-ce
qu'on est d'accord avec ça
on a créé de la monnaie pendant covid-19
les banques à mon centrale européenne
est racheté les obligations les états
des machins ça se passe pas le faire
tourner le truc donc à un moment il y
aurait eu il y a forcément de
l'inflation qui est venue il y avait
déjà et de façon mais s'il y avait pas
eu la guerre en Ukraine cette inflation
ce serait sans doute déjà un peu
amplifié si rajoute le coût de l'énergie
ça ça fait la deuxième lame c'est celle
qu'on ressent vraiment fort là depuis
depuis ouais février mars avril très
bien et puis elle a la troisième lame
qui arrive et c'est ça le saut dans
l'inconnu pour moi c'est pas le blackout
le blackout ça va bien se passer moi je
on a des gens compétents qui bossent
dans tout ça machin ça va bien se passer
allumer quelques groupes électrogènes de
6 de là moi je pense que voilà ça sera
tournant donc pendant deux heures ok ma
machine va tourner je pense que ça ça
c'est si ça se passe au niveau français
au niveau européen oui d'accord voilà
donc moi je pense que voilà mais la
troisième lame c'est tout le monde qui
dit ah oui mais combien 5% de
d'inflation ou 7% 8% enfin quelques
quand on veut je vais être augmenter
d'autant
alors du coup
attention tu n'es pas économiste non
justement non mais voilà non mais moi je
rêverais que les économistes qui va se
passer mais c'est un peu comme les
météorologues ils t'explique mieux ce
qui s'est passé que ce qui va se passer
j'ai rien contre les météorologues à ne
pas confondre avec les climatologues qui
travaillent et te disent des trucs à 100
ans mais eux ils valident modèle le
météorologue et là il dit il va pleuvoir
puis des fois finalement il a pas plu
mais il t'explique pourquoi mais ça peut
arriver donc des économies je sais pas
si je bosse enfin si j'espère qu'il
bossent un peu sur ça mais
j'avoue que j'ai assez peu de
je sais pas comment dire ça
n'a pas marché ouais j'ai du mal à avoir
vraiment un très un énorme respect
intellectuel pour pour beaucoup
d'économistes voilà mais bon c'est comme
ça mais bon
donc le donc là voilà la troisième lame
c'est ça c'est l'inflation des salaires
de partout pas que dans les domaines où
on consomme de l'énergie mais dans le
domaine des services etc et donc je
pense que le ce qu'on subit là même on
évolution de du prix des patates ou des
pâtes ou je sais pas quoi c'est c'est
l'inflation c'est pas juste l'inflation
énergétique c'est l'inflation
énergétique plus déjà les premières
lames des mesures de rattrapage salarial
etc de prime de partage de la valeur je
sais pas quoi qui ont été déjà accordés
en 2022 et donc ont déjà fait monter le
truc moi ce qui me pourquoi je dis que
c'est un saut dans l'inconnu parce qu'en
fait c'est la fameuse spirale inflation
salaire ok donc dans les années 60-60 ça
se passe bien tout ça on achète sa truc
à crédit et puis les prix montent mais
les salaires montent aussi et là en fait
il y a un moment où on paye quand même
plus cher à l'extérieur des trucs genre
le gaz genre donc il y a un moment faut
entre guillemets ça peut ouvrir quand je
dis ça peut ouvrir pas personnellement
chacun mais collectivement donc si tout
le monde est augmenté à la vitesse à
laquelle il y a l'inflation et yuklaboom
tout va bien ça ça marche pas enfin
c'est le truc s'emballe forcément quoi
va me semble-t-il donc c'est je dis ça
avec une grande naïveté d'ingénieurs et
donc je serais ravi que les économistes
m'expliquent que je me je me trompe
complètement et
je comprends rien aux histoires de taux
d'intérêt je sais pas quoi mais c'est
quand même un peu sa idée donc du coup
c'est pour moi c'est cette inflation là
c'est cette couche d'inflation qui est
en train de venir et donc et après quand
tu dis oui quand les gens ont faim ils
vont se mettre sur les ronds non pour
avoir faim il faut vraiment avoir faim
pour se mettre en face de gens qui tape
dessus y compris ou alors être vraiment
vexé et avoir aussi des questions de
fierté moi je pense que malheureusement
effectivement il y a un sentiment très
fort n'a pauvrement parce que il y a un
pourcentage de plus en plus important
aussi de dépenses contraintes qui sont
les dépenses de logement donc j'ai pas
revenir encore sur sur la ville et tout
parce que en ce moment ça me passionne
mais tu as des gens qui font la culbute
d'un côté parce que on passe d'une terre
agricole un terrain constructible c'est
pas que des agriculteurs voilà c'est
souvent deuxième troisième génération
des foncières enfin plein de gens il y a
plein de gens qui bouffent là-dessus je
passe de quelques euros du mètre carré à
quelques dizaines d'euros du mètre carré
pour faire simple donc youplin c'est
l'équivalent du revenu des agriculteurs
en France en ordre de grandeur chaque
année c'est
value cette manne et pour payer cette
manne il y a des gens qui eux
s'endettent sur 25 ou 30 ans donc ça
c'est voilà c'est une dépense contrainte
dépenses contraintes dépenses
contraintes des forfaits de Netflix de
machin et donc à la fin voilà c'est dans
quoi on tape je suis pas sûr que à un
moment voilà on peut taper dans la
nourriture si on respecte pas bien les 5
fruits par jour mais tu peux aussi taper
dans d'autres choses aujourd'hui les
gens ils ont tapé dans le cinéma ils ont
tapé dans des trucs culturels enfin on
voit bien et d'ailleurs il y a c'est un
mélange avec la grande flemme de tout à
l'heure c'est les gens vont plus au
cinéma parce que c'est cher et en plus
parce qu'il faut quitter son canapé donc
ça fait un double truc c'est pas sympa
bon de plus en plus d'étudiants enfin
quand j'étais étudiant il y a une
vingtaine d'années je me rappelle pas
bien des histoires de banques
alimentaires des gens qui faisaient la
queue pour pouvoir bouffer c'est au
début
bah écoute moi ça m'est arrivé d'aller
dîner au CROUS ça coûtait pas très cher
le restaurant l'universitaire bah non
mais ça m'arrive ça fait des études
bourgeoises
je me souviens je vais payer quelque
chose
pour 4-5 euros
moi je alors de la famille l'ingénieur
qui essaie de faire l'économie
la deuxième version moi pour aborder
dans le saut de l'inconnu j'ai
l'impression qu'on est quand même à la
fin d'un cycle à la fin d'un cycle et
j'en parlais ce midi qui est peut-être
été un peu instauré par le général de
Gaulle qui en 1968 a décidé de récupérer
son or aux États-Unis et qu'est-ce que
c'est à quoi ça aboutit à la fin des
accords de Bretton wood parce que tout
le monde voulait récupérer son or et
donc ils ont dû décorer la monnaie d'un
truc physique et donc à partir de 70 et
aussi avec le les chocs pétroliers on
n'arrivait plus à augmenter la
production de pétrole de 8% par an on a
commencé à s'endetter à imprimer de
l'argent c'est ça qui nous a fait choc
inflationniste aussi qu'on a eu à ce
moment-là avec des taux d'intérêt qui
sont montés très haut etc
j'ai l'impression qu'on est un petit peu
à la fin de ces cycles là qui a du 50
ans et sauf que là la différence c'est
qu'il y a 50 ans quand on commençait on
n'avait pas de dette puisqu'on
commençait du pétrole facilement
accessible
chercher un Alaska etc au départ et ça
coûtait cher
sauf qu'aujourd'hui on est assis sur
3000 milliards de dettes en France 3000
milliards en Italie peut-être 25000
milliards aux États-Unis je parle que
d'être publique et donc on retrouve le
même contexte infassionniste sauf que en
73 on avait un choc pétroly là on a un
choc pétrolier un choc gazier un choc
entre guillemets électricité on a trois
pour le prix d'un
quelle est la solution des banques
centrales c'est de calmer calmer
l'inflation donc on va augmenter les
taux ce qu'elles font toujours quand on
a une surchauffe elle l'avait fait en
2003 2004 aussi quand la Chine avait
rejoint l'OMC en 2001 et donc
appris toute la console de pétrole c'est
pour ça que les prix étaient montés à
150 dollars du baril en 2008
mais sauf que quand vous montez les taux
et que vous avez 3 milliards de dettes
c'est terminé c'est game mauvais en fait
vous pouvez pas tu banqueroute
tranquillement et tu repars
la solution a priori pour l'instant ce
que j'ai compris de la Banque centrale
américaine la fête c'est de d'envoyer
l'économie dans le mur bon bah quand
vous envoyez l'économie dans le mur les
prix bien évidemment vont diminuer mais
nous en Europe sur le gaz en fait on
n'est pas sorti de l'auberge peu de gens
le savent parce que mais le gars c'est
l'énergie la transition énergétique
c'est grâce au gaz naturel que les
émissions de CO2 ont baissé depuis une
quinzaine d'années parce que ça a permis
de remplacer le charbon dans la
production d'électricité dans la
production de chaleur et que ce soit aux
États-Unis y compris ce Donald Trump en
Allemagne
ou encore en Chine où on a beaucoup
substitué du charbon par du gaz les
émissions de CO2 elles ont baissé parce
qu'on a remplacé du charbon par du gaz
et en plus c'est aussi une énergie qui
peut être complémentaire avec les
renouvelables intermittents parce que
dès qu'il y a moins de vent ou pas de
soleil on appuie sur un bouton on a
notre centrale à gaz juste un exemple je
reprends l'Allemagne l'Allemagne si en
98 qui rage rauder n'avait pas fait son
alliance avec les écolos et avec décidé
de sortir du nucléaire en 20 temps
l'Allemagne ne consommerait pas une
goutte de gaz pour produire son
électricité aujourd'hui
et donc aujourd'hui sur le gaz
malheureusement
moi c'est vrai que je regarde avec
l'association politique du pic pétrolier
les disponibilités de pétrole et de gaz
mais c'est vrai qu'on s'attendait pas à
cette situation effectivement ou du jour
au lendemain l'Europe se prive de la
Russie 40% d'approvisionnement gaz juste
une anecdote là-dessus pour voir qu'on
est un peu oui
en 2014 2014 donc il y a le coup d'État
romaïda dans l'Ukraine Vladimir Poutine
annexe la Crimée
à l'époque l'Europe et autosuffisante en
gaz de 40% donc le produit il y a 40 %
son propre gaz
mais notamment on a un grand Shanghai
qui est le champ de Groeningen au
Pays-Bas et qui qui en déclament et qui
est aussi va être fermé parce qu'on a eu
des problèmes de tremblement de terre
etc et donc on est passé de 40% en 2014
à 10%
voilà et la baisse des champs
où est-ce qu'on allait chercher les 30%
. alors que
Monsieur Poutine Alexis
on est chercher en Russie
donc donc on a on a quand même pu se
dire attention attention à notre
dépendance moi je me souviens très bien
on en avait parlé avec une conférence
économique attention à nos dépendances
d'où vient l'énergie à qui on l'achète
est-ce que on a des plans B on n'a
jamais regardé de plan B on n'a jamais
regardé d'alternative et aujourd'hui
mais on ne regarde toujours pas
l'alternative on s'en remet au ciel
alors on va rester sur ces belles
paroles
est-ce que vous voulez aborder un sujet
qu'on n'a pas aborder ou est-ce que vous
voulez passer tout de suite aux trois
bouquins que vous voulez conseiller avec
un conseil pour les jeunes générations
de précision sur Internet qu'est-ce que
ça signifie s'approuvrir collectivement
virgule passer à la décroissance point
d'interrogation
ça veut dire que le gâteau a partagé et
moins grand une certaine manière donc on
se castagne pour avoir la dernière
possible avec avec certains qui font
plus d'efforts que d'autres parce que
ils ont plus de marge de manœuvre ça ça
marche pas ça alors voilà en général
c'est le plus fort le plus balèze qui
tape sur le petit non tu as des
mécanismes de retraite de redistribution
quand même qui s'appelle comment
l'évasion fiscale ça non non mais ça
peut être ça je pense que j'ai toi qui a
répondu Nicolas mais sur la sur la
question de dire est-ce qu'on va avoir
encore des crises sociales ou autre donc
si je passe un petit épi phénomène ça
s'appelle la question des retraites là
qui est en train d'arriver là quand même
donc qui va se créer quelques remous
mais qui sont plus
voilà qui sont qui sont plus standards
plus plus connu en termes de terrain
potentiellement mais
moi je pense que ce qui est ce qui va
faire le sujet c'est c'est l'exemplarité
l'exemplarité des élites ou pas
c'est-à-dire tant qu'on est encore avec
des gens qui sont qui vivent dans un
autre univers qui sont pas soumis au
contrainte économiques dont on parlait
tout à l'heure sous-estimer son patron
de 50%
, c'est l'exemple c'est l'inflation
ouais c'est la chance
[Musique]
l'amnésie sélective la phobie
administrative
parce que évidemment ça ça projette vers
le verre de populisme vers enfin voilà
c'est vrai que c'est je pense que ça va
être pour moi ça va être vraiment un
sujet on voit bien que ça se tend et ça
se tend pas que entre ce compas d'argent
et ce qu'on a beaucoup je pense que ça
se sent aussi et bien dans les jeunes
élites
intellectuels des grandes écoles et je
sais pas quoi on voit quand même que ça
se il y en a quelques-uns qui essayent
de se rebeller un peu et c'est pas
inintéressant et c'est justement ces
sujets d'exemplarité d'entraînement
voilà c'est alors on peut évidemment se
rappeler les heures les plus sombres de
l'histoire avec je sais pas quoi
Roosevelt et sa femme qui qui jardinent
dans la Maison Blanche et je sais pas
quoi mais bon non ça va ce que ça vaut
mais voilà c'est aujourd'hui on voit
bien que
euh quand ils essayent de de soit il
donne pas du tout l'exemple et c'est
vraiment très effrayant soit quand ils
essayent de le donner c'est un peu avec
des gros sabots et puis c'est on enfile
le plus la colle roulé et puis après on
s'étonne d'être un peu bâché sur les
réseaux sociaux bon parce que c'est mal
fait quoi parce qu'on sent que parce
qu'on sent pas forcément de la sincérité
derrière c'est ça le sujet en fait c'est
ça c'est hérité aujourd'hui de nos
dirigeants y compris sur leur capacité à
pas forcément tout maîtriser donc c'est
le c'est le seul truc un peu positif je
trouve dans cette phrase de débutant
c'est que voilà elle reconnaît que on
maîtrise pas tout on maîtrise pas le
ciel au sens météorologique bon ben
voilà et donc on va voir ce qu'on fait
on va faire mieux possible mais ça sera
pas forcément parfait et je pense que ce
discours sincérité il faut que faut
qu'il s'amplifie il faut qu'il reprenne
on a été évidemment très attaqué le
discours de sincérité il y a quand même
la grande tarte
une certaine manière verront à sa petite
échelle sur le sur le covid après il y a
un autre aspect c'est de dire si on se
retrouve à judiciarisé comme des malades
en disant à chaque fois qu'il y en a un
qui montera qui sera ministre il va
finir à la Cour de Justice de la
République parce que il sera responsable
de tout
je suis pas sûr que ça donne envie non
plus à des gens de qualité de monter au
créneau quoi donc il y a aussi cette
question là
donc il faut en prendre pour faire de
l'exemple genre une bonne séance de
guitare comme il va bien histoire de
faire un bon exemple
non je suis pas sûr parce que je sais
pas je sais pas qu'il faudrait choisir
mais je pense qu'il faut être plus
inflexible sur
Non mais voilà ceux qui sont vraiment
pris les mains dans le pot de confiture
il faut être plus inflexible peut-être
qu'on est aujourd'hui on est sur des
questions d'innigibilité par exemple
voilà
question Internet vous savez c'est le
temps Nicolas de réfléchir moi j'avais
mon truc allez vas-y file parce qu'on a
parlé de des industrialisation on a
parlé des gros industriels il y a des
gens qu'on n'a pas parlé qui sont les
plus impactés
c'est nos boulangers un peu est-ce qu'on
a pas parlé des boulangers boulangers
chercher
en Irlande un par semaine qui ferme les
prix bouchons par semaine les primeurs
les pêcheurs les agriculteurs toutes ces
PME toutes les TPE c'est 50% de l'emploi
en France il y a plein de métiers qui
sont dans des localisables donc ça veut
dire qu'ils vont quand même fermer et
qui souffrent et qui sont souvent en
fait c'est des oublis du système donc
ils sont mis couverts en haut ni couvert
en bas ils sont dans le dans le ils ont
des prix j'écoute j'entendais quelqu'un
là qui fabriquait les pulls
en Bretagne exemple il fabrique des
plans Bretagne il se donne du mal pour
fabriquer en France il a sa facture
d'électricité qui multipliée par 5
qu'est-ce qui fait pour la payer mais il
est obligé de 5% de son effectif enfin
et aujourd'hui ce qui est incroyable
c'est que qui sont les gens qui vont
souffrir de cette ce sont pas les
entreprises qui fabriquent déjà en Chine
en Tunisie au Maroc au machin eux ils
s'en foutent ça change rien pour eux
tous les mecs qui se donnent du mal pour
aller produire en France et créer une
langue en France c'est ceux qui font le
plus dégommer et donc on est quand même
dans ce mouvement où tous les petits
vont disparaître
il va rester que des gros et ça c'est
quand même assez préoccupant parce que
les petits c'est quand même beaucoup
d'emplois et c'est aussi beaucoup
d'innovation d'Internet
qu'est-ce que je fais de ma twingo de
1998 je la change pour une nouvelle
essence je passe à l'hybride à
l'électrique avec les primes d'état ou
je la garde et je la rafistole cher
à la question d'abord c'est qu'est-ce
qui fait avec cette Twingo à quoi elle
sert est-ce qu'il utilise tous les jours
ou pas la question de la mobilité déjà
il faut la prendre à partir d'abord du
besoin quel est votre usage est-ce que
tous les jours vous pouvez aller au
travail différemment qu'en voiture parce
que souvent les problèmes de la mobilité
c'est pas en ville dans les Smart City
c'est au milieu rural en périurbain où
il n'y a pas de transport en commun et
on n'a pas le choix sachant un chiffre
intéressant que des horaires où tu peux
pas prendre un transport en commun parce
que tu travailles la nuit parce que tu
embauches à 5h du mat etc exactement
donc ce qu'il faudrait déjà un chiffre
intéressant un calcul de Jean-Marc donc
ici aujourd'hui on le choix qu'on a mis
150 milliards d'euros pour développer
des énergies renouvelables
intermittentes et aux liens solaires
d'une façon le moment pas eu beaucoup
d'impact sur nos émissions de CO2 un
petit peu plus sur notre balance
commerciale puisque c'est fabriqué en
Chine souvent
pour 100 milliards d'euros vous doublez
toutes les routes de France d'une piste
cyclable 100 milliards pour moins cher
que ça parce qu'aujourd'hui quand on est
à la campagne et qu'on veut prendre son
vélo avec beaucoup de bonnes volonté
c'est pas comme le curé il y a 50 ans il
y a quand même les 44 tonnes il faut
covoiturer avec eux et donc d'avoir une
piste cyclable plus un vélo électrique
ça vous emmène assez loin ça vous emmène
entre 10 et 15 km et donc on pourrait
résoudre beaucoup de problèmes comme ça
et peut-être que la Twingo pourrait
rester au garage maintenant il a pas le
choix quel est son problème avec cette
Twingo de 98 c'est que personnellement
demain il pourra plus rentrer en ville
il va être chassé il va être chassé des
villes la solution idéale qui va
solution d'ailleurs de Cuba qu'est-ce
qu'on aurait fait à Cuba on aurait
appris le moteur on aura enlevé on
aurait mis un petit moteur électrique
ça coûte très cher à Cuba ils ont
remplacé des moteurs des voitures
américaines par des moteurs de camions
russes un sujet pas de bêtises donc
c'est spécial mais la meilleure chose
c'est ça ce serait de
qui passe des mini de des anciennes mini
alors c'est plutôt les voitures de
collection très très belle mais il faut
fournir la Mini et ça coûte encore 10 ou
4000 € pour juste mettre un moteur
électrique dedans et la remasterise quoi
c'est toujours le problème du recyclage
c'est que ça coûte dans des industries
comme l'automobile qui est l'industrie
d'échelle c'est que ça coûte toujours
moins cher d'acheter du neuf que de
l'acheter de l'occasion parce que le
temps de travail qui va être nécessaire
pour le changer alors si les bricoleurs
c'est mieux mais après la batterie elle
va l'écouter cher quand même donc
donc si les bricoleurs il se fait une
twingo électrique
ça dépend ça dépend faut vraiment partir
de ça dépend de son usage c'est à dire
que si il utilise tous les jours ou
utilise tous les week-ends
carbone de la voiture électrique il est
à 4 pays quand la France moins si on
importe des trucs au gaz ou aux limites
allemands mais grosso modo c'est 80%
c'est la fabrication quoi donc ensuite
si on la plante en sortant de l'usine on
a vraiment vraiment un très mauvais
bilan carbone c'est-à-dire on utilise
tous les jours ça bosse pour des taxis
je sais pas quoi là au contraire c'est
un bilan carbone génial et donc il y a
quand même cette histoire de profil de
nombre de kilomètres qui seront
effectivement réalisés
j'ai finalement deux de neurones qu'on
lui souhaite connecter en fait
aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup de gilets
jaunes qui roulent en retour électrique
en Renault Zoé il roule pas en Tesla il
roule en Renault
avant que les prix électricité soit
multipliés par 4 donc pour l'instant les
particuliers sont entre guillemets
protégées on peut on peut imaginer qu'il
y aura des choses qui vont être mises en
place pour en tout cas les protéger sur
cette partie de recharge de voiture
électrique et moi je connais beaucoup de
gens modestes qui roulent avec ces
voitures là parce que ça leur coûte
moins cher sans être de l'État sans rien
zéro après je pense que votre de Twingo
elle vous servait pas forcément à partir
au ski et donc la Zoé vous servira pas
non plus aller au ski parce que vous
n'aurez pas la batterie pour mais pour
les trajets du quotidien c'est parfait
si j'ai bien compris les forfaits de ski
ont explosé
et donc juste un détail petite question
personnelle
un Hidalgo m'a obligé à changer ma
voiture bien j'étais content mon fidèle
destrier de 10 ans et 100 000 kilomètres
comme neuf garantit un million de
kilomètres
durant ces 10 ans j'étais obligé de
changer une lumière de clignotant et un
contrôleur de clim à 49,99
. je suis interdit d'aller à Paris moi
j'étais repousse un petit peu ils
avaient peur qu'on mette le feu
c'était une bonne mesure d'imposer aux
gens qui avaient des voitures qui
fonctionnaient très très bien qui
consommaient que dalle est-ce que
c'était intelligent de leur faire
changer de voiture
est-ce que c'était pas un petit peu on
va exporter les maladies
cardiovasculaires et respiratoires en
dehors des grandes villes parce que vos
voitures de pauvres n'en veut plus chez
vous
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette histoire
c'était une petite lubie c'était un truc
encore pas réfléchi c'était pour faire
passer les kilomètres de piste cyclab à
Paris
qu'est-ce que c'était
sur le papier sur le papier
de se dire que les voitures les plus
anciennes sont celles qui polluent le
plus et qu'on va les limiter
à condition d'avoir des alternatives
c'est pas complètement déconnant le
problème c'est qu'en fait les voitures
qui polluent le plus c'est les plus
récentes
en fait avec le scandale Volkswagen ce
qu'on a vu et notamment lors de la
pollution vous avez les émissions de
particules fines et des émissions de
dioxyde d'azote et en fait par exemple
la ville de Paris de Anne Hidalgo ne
respecte pas la réglementation sur le
dioxyde d'azote depuis 2010
mais c'est sur ça il suffit de regarder
le niveau de la limite je crois que
c'est 40 microgrammes par mètre cube ou
un truc comme ça mais c'est surtout
sourcé parce que vous tapez et que et
que la France a été attaquée plusieurs
fois par la Commission européenne parce
qu'elle est respectée pas depuis 12 ans
12 ans la réglementation le dioxyde
d'azote d'où il vient il vient des
véhicules diesel donc il y a des
voitures mais il y a aussi les camions
les bus les camionnettes etc
et en fait le scandale Volkswagen
qu'est-ce qu'il a montré il a montré que
les véhicules les plus récents étaient
plus de dioxyde d'azote que des
véhicules plus anciens donc en fait même
si sur le papier cette idée passe
stupide en fait aujourd'hui elle va
encourager les voitures qui polluent le
plus sur le corps sur le carburant
aurait-il traficier
il était ils ont arrêté de trafiquer
mais c'est quand même toujours des
voitures qui émettent beaucoup de
dioxyde d'azote et comme on a beaucoup
de diesel je suis pas sûr qu'on soit
rentré dans les clous
sur ce polluant là
j'étais allé à la mairie de Paris avec
une entreprise qui travaille dans le
covoiturage en fait le problème des
voitures c'est que ça prend beaucoup
trop de place pour être rempli que par
une seule personne dans une ville et
donc j'avais dit bah en fait
ce qu'il faut c'est qu'il est plus une
seule voiture avec une personne donc il
faut mettre deux personnes trois
personnes on a des portiques tout neufs
qui nous ont coûté quelque chose comme
je sais pas si c'est 800 millions
d'euros dont on sait jamais servi qui
pourrait voir s'il y a une ou deux
personnes dans la voiture les américains
ils font ça depuis 50 ans ça s'appelle
les lignes pour de l'autopartage on
pourrait plutôt que de pénaliser les
gens et d'ailleurs sur un critère
d'argent parce que ceux qui sont riches
ils ont les moyens il y aura pas de
problème mais allez dire à celui qui
roule dans son grand Range Rover que
s'il veut rentrer en ville il va falloir
prendre quelqu'un à côté de lui là tout
le monde est sur le même pied l'égalité
et donc l'idée c'était de dire voilà
plus de voitures avec une seule personne
qu'elle soit diesel essence des années
60 ou 2020 je m'en fous mais je veux des
gens deux personnes par bagnole et ça
pour moi c'est quelque chose de
pertinent et aujourd'hui le levier le
plus puissant de sobriété sur le pétrole
c'est de remplir ces bagnoles notamment
pas pour partir en vacances parce que
Philippe en parle avec moi il y a
beaucoup d'effets rebonds mais sur le
trajet contraint du domicile travail si
vous avez une personne qui vont en
voiture au travail et des voitures et
vous les mettez dans une voiture ils
vont pas aller plus au travail ils vont
pas y aller le week-end ou supprimer une
voiture ou supprimer la consommation de
carburant la pollution le bruit l'espace
etc et donc aujourd'hui
en fait on a donné cette milliards
d'euros aux Français avec la richtone
sur le carburant c'est 7 milliards
d'euros il fallait les donner aux
collectivités parce qu'on sait que si
les collectivités commencent à
subventionner le covoiturage comme elle
subventionne le transport en commun et
bien là on va être capable de supprimer
des voitures et de baisser
significativement notre consommation de
carburant et accessoirement de permettre
aux gens qui ne peuvent plus se payer et
de se déplacer comme peut-être cette
personne en Twingo d'aller travailler
parce que on est capable de faire du
covoiturage dès que sur un emplacement
de on a 300 personnes qui travaillent
sur le même site pas forcément dans les
entreprises vous avez la densité
suffisante pour pouvoir trouver
quelqu'un qui habite pas loin de chez
vous et donc une fois que ma voiture a
été interdite par une idée le groupe
il fallait faire quoi
elle est racheter une voiture neuve
électrique que qu'on peut pas se payer
il fallait racheter une voiture neuve
thermique qu'on peut à peu près se payer
fallait racheter une voiture d'occasion
fallait pas racheter de voiture
réponse A B C ou D
bah il faut il faut regarder une fois de
plus en retard du besoin on part du
besoin ou pas où est-ce que où est-ce
que vous travaillez est-ce qu'on est
capable déjà de peut-être de se
rapprocher de il faut se passer au
maximum de sa voiture et ça c'est
vraiment ce qu'il faut avoir en tête
et d'ailleurs sur je reprends juste
l'exemple notre gouvernement dit enfin
c'est pas le gouvernement c'est le
Robert
2035 on vend que des voitures
électriques
et pour viser de neutralité carbone en
2050 ce qui serait pertinent parce que
moi quand on pose la question est-ce que
c'est intelligent ou pas je dis que
c'est complètement stupide parce qu'en
fait ce qui est pertinent c'est de te
dire aujourd'hui tout de suite
maintenant on va manquer le pétrole donc
il faut se passer du pétrole le plus
rapidement possible là où on peut le
faire où est-ce qu'on peut le faire on
peut le faire dans les trajets du
quotidien c'est là où on n'a pas besoin
de pétrole quand on se déplace en ville
bien évidemment quand on a du transport
en commun et donc on pourrait viser en
2030 80% de la mobilité sans pétrole 80%
pourquoi parce que la mobilité c'est 80%
du trajet du quotidien 20% de la longue
distance et donc c'est ça qu'il faut
viser à tout prix et donc il faut voir
dans quelle mesure on peut se passer de
sa voiture pour aller au travail soit on
se rapprochant de son travail soit en
prenant un vélo en transport en commun
et si on peut pas se passer de sa
voiture dans ce cas là on loue une
Renault Zoé d'occasion à 100 euros par
mois et on trouve quelqu'un pour
covoiturer pour payer l'électricité et
la location chaque choix unitaire est
hyper compliqué de façon donc on peut
pas donner un conseil comme ça la bonne
solution ça aurait été celle-là mais je
trouve que ça illustre très bien le fait
qu'on vit dans une économie poussée
poussée par les constructeurs et pas
tiré par les clients ça c'est aussi une
magie d'économiste c'est à dire
l'économie est tirée puis on va tous
devenir écoconsommateur ça va être
génial et non pas du tout c'est poussé
donc il faut imposer au constructeur de
faire des bagnoles vachement moins cher
vachement moins équipées
en fait une fine et de toute manière
pourquoi pas après tout non mais why not
un arceau de sécurité à l'intérieur j'en
sais rien non non mais c'est c'est
tellement tellement plus simple
simplement évidemment avec les gains de
productivité phénoménaux Colosso qui a
eu depuis bah ouais des années 70-80
enfin la robotisation etc une bagnole on
va dire moins polluante quand même parce
que tu as un peu électronique et tout
dedans
mais qui pèserait le même poids et qui
serait aussi peu équipé qui est une
bagnole du début des années 80 ça
vaudrait rien
ça vaudrait je sais pas 1500 balles neuf
peut-être 202000 balles inflation
comprise parce que les gains ont été
finalement donc pour lutter contre cette
déflation pour lutter contre le risque
de baisse du chiffre d'affaires parce
qu'évidemment il faut toujours monter le
chiffre d'affaires il a fallu enrichir
et alourdir les voitures il y a eu aussi
un petit peu de quand même de critères
de sécurité qui fait que voilà il y a
quand même la sécurité passive des
voitures qui les a alourdis mais pas que
ce sont alourdis parce que c'est c'est
le marketing voilà c'est les SUV etc
donc il faut forcer la main là-dessus il
faut que tu as un point de vue
réglementaire on n'a pas le droit de
rouler avec des chars d'assaut et ben on
doit pas avoir droit de rouler avec des
bagnoles de 2 tonnes il faut que et du
coup en ouvrira la porte un business de
voiture beaucoup plus petite et puis
effectivement on pourra développer en
parallèle le vélo transport en commun
tout ce qu'il faut mais c'est mais il
faut agir sur ce sur ce critère lutter
contre l'effet rebond c'est l'effet
rebond on a des voitures efficaces mais
plus lourdes
au Japon ils ont mis en place quelque
chose qui s'appelle les key car qui sont
des petites voitures magnifiques font 3
mètres 40 de long si je dis pas de
bêtises et en gros si vous voulez vous
acheter une voiture vous habitez à Tokyo
soit vous pouvez vous avez une place de
stationnement soit les seules voitures
pouvaient acheter ce sont ceux qui et
donc c'est 40 %. donc de voiture sur 5
vendues au Japon qui ont des carrés et
là depuis trois mois ils viennent de les
lancer en mode électrique et ça pour moi
c'est la voiture du futur parce que
c'est parfaitement dimensionné pour
couvrir tout le trajet du quotidien
exactement
quatre personnes on peut rentrer à 4
dedans parce que Smart c'est que deux
japonais quatre mois un peu sérieux
trêve de plaisanterie question taquine
de Ford Fiesta c'est le même
style ou pas être très taquine
peuvent-ils nous parler du bilan C2 des
agrocarburants français notamment le
bioéthanol E85
alors quand c'est jaune dans les champs
ça veut dire carburant c'est ça
on a eu une erreur méthodologique au
tout début sur le
sur les agro-carburants vraiment alors
je sais plus quand c'était mais dans les
années 2000 où il y a on a fait des
calculs il y a eu des calculs des
analyses de cycle de vie qui ont été
faites avec les intrants effectivement
le donc le CO2 quelque part
correspondant à fabriquer l'hydrogène
pour fabriquer des engrais le fioul du
tracteur etc et puis en fait à un moment
quand on fait des quand on fait des des
trucs comme ça il y a soit on récupère
enfin on récupère la graine et puis il y
a le il y a les tourteaux qui vont
servir à être mélangés avec d'autres
trucs et du coup on avait réparti le CO2
au prorata du poids
du coup ça avait fait un bilan carbone
plutôt sympa pour pour le je suis pas
sûr on est fait exprès en fait parce que
c'était des gens plutôt bien qui avait
fait ça mais il fallait en fait il fait
une clé de répartition c'est ça le
problème du bilan carbone c'est un truc
hyper compliqué si je suis sur une
chaîne même sur Google par exemple c'est
quoi le poids d'une requête sur Google
on a les émissions de CO2 du datacenter
par contre la part du datacenter qui
bosse sur Gmail par qui bosse sur le
Cloud et la partie bosse sur la requête
Google bah ça c'est ce crâne industriel
donc on peut pas en train de te parler
d'un truc qu'on fait pousser dans un
champ quoi oui mais du coup il y avait
quand même ce truc de il y avait quand
même la question de la clé de
répartition donc ils avaient choisi une
clé de répartition en poids avec ce truc
là ça faisait un truc qui était
intéressant
répartition je le garde je te le pic la
prochaine engueulade avec ma chérie
attends après ça a été revu et en fait
on a dit bah non en fait si on fait
pousser ce truc c'est quand même pour
faire d'abord des agro carburants et
puis le truc à côté le tourteau c'est un
c'est un copro mais on n'a pas donc on
va le tout sur et à ce moment là on
tombe un truc genre à virgule un pour un
ou un truc assez ça devient totalement
absurde quelque part de faire les agro
carburants en Europe
sauf en temps de guerre
ouais bien sûr par contre ça reste
intéressant quand tu le fais à partir de
canne à sucre je sais pas quoi et puis
tropicaux et puis après il y a d'autres
effets que la question juste du carbone
c'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui si tu fais
du biodiel alors c'est pas la partie
euthanol mais à partir de l'huile de
palme on a donné qui arrive d'Indonésie
de enfin de Sumatra et de Bornéo bah là
tu as d'autres problèmes que le CO2
malheureusement et donc ça manque
d'orangs-outan au bout d'un moment quoi
donc voilà donc agroc carburant la
réponse c'est que on a un problème de
compétition alimentaire et en fait on
sait pas passer à la génération 2 qui
est de travailler que avec le résidu de
la plante c'est pas du tout près d'un
point de vue même sur la paillasse c'est
pas prêt donc d'un point de viend
industriel c'est encore plus loin donc
on reste sur la génération qui est en
compétition frontale avec commentaires
quoi qu'il arrive la génération 3
c'était les micro-algues pareil tout le
monde s'excitait il y a 10 ans
maintenant c'est plus personne en parle
non plus c'est ça a tourné aux
technophflops pour plein de raisons donc
voilà c'est malheureusement pas génial
et c'est vrai que c'est un peu terrible
de se dire que quoi qu'il arrive c'est
rempli son réservoir on déforest le peu
qu'il reste en Asie du Sud-Est c'est pas
sympa
pour faire voler les avions verts
pourtant si j'ai bien compris le jet des
diabète pour les signer un peu près ça
laquelle réussi à aller faire un
aller-retour à Marseille en jet et
revenir le soir même pour une émission
sur BFM qui parlait du climat en 2050
je te vois toi là-bas dans le coin
trêve de plaisanterie nous arrivons à la
fin de notre interview on a essayé de
faire court deux heures
et ça fait des années qu'on parle
d'énergie toute la communauté toute
notre communauté et bien rompu à ce type
d'exercice et en ayant des très fiers
d'eux d'avoir suivi
nos interviews depuis si longtemps sur
des sujets si arides merci encore d'être
là Philippe Wix est-ce que vous avez
trois bouquins est-ce que tu as trois
bouquins est conseillé à notre
communauté et dans la même foulée un
conseil pour les jeunes générations et
le mot de la fin sera pour Nicolas
meilleur d'accord du coup faut pas le
tester de ce que j'ai raconté comme
trois bouquins des fois d'avant parce
qu'en fait j'oublie complètement et si
ça se trouve ça va être à nouveau les
mêmes ou plus important c'est des
bouquins qui ont compté pour toi alors
ok
mais j'avais envie d'être c'est sympa là
c'est on est un peu en période c'est
l'hiver tout ça c'est pas sympa ça va
être l'hiver donc un peu de fun donc
alors un roman le gang de la clé à
molette par Edward Abbey
donc c'est c'est une histoire
complètement délirante aux États-Unis de
de saboteur écolo bon je dis pas qu'il
faut saboter des trucs c'est pas ça mais
le truc est très très drôle non plus
c'est hilarant c'est vraiment chouette
ça des années 70
Édouard d'abeille qui est un personnage
assez étonnant derrière qui a aussi créé
un bouquin qui s'appelle désert
solitaire peu importe après un deuxième
alors un peu un mode collapso mais c'est
un roman en fait très ancien de George
Stewart je crois Stewart en tout cas qui
s'appelle la terre demeure c'est un
espèce de truc horrible où tout le monde
meurt sauf quelques personnes donc mais
en fait au-delà de ça c'est un roman sur
la transmission sur la capacité en fait
à transmettre une complexité
technologique en fait alors qu'au début
moi je spoil pas mais ils bouffe tous
des boîtes de conserve tout le monde
hyper riche quoi les survivants qui
restent ils sont là ils bossent pas et
tout clairement on dit mais merde il
faut qu'on apprenne à faire des trucs
parce qu'à un moment il y aura plus de
stock quoi et donc c'est une espèce de
c'est pas mal écrit je trouve c'est
assez sympa
et puis le troisième
je l'ai pas
un conseil pour les jeunes générations
déprimé pas déprimez pas c'est dans la
faut pas déprimer surtout on a essayé ça
va être un peu ça va être un peu dingue
en fait on va avoir plein de positions
les positions d'acteurs d'observateurs
ça va secouer ça a bougé on va être
surpris mais ça va être aussi marrant
finalement une certaine manière ça sera
très dur dans d'autres cas mais en fait
je pense que c'est on c'est dans
l'action qu'on peut se trouver sous
toutes ses formes donc soyez engagés
voilà ça fait un peu engagez-vous je
sais pas quoi
indignez-vous je les ai plus mais ça
fait surtout l'action sœur du rêve ouais
ben voilà très bien donc c'est pas juste
c'est pas juste des prospectives à 2050
et je sais pas quoi là là ça va aller
mal non non c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait
là tout de suite la semaine prochaine le
mois prochain dans un an et comment on
construit on évolue comment on fait son
trajet de vie professionnelle
personnelle et voilà faut y aller il
faut cogner dans la butte quoi il y a
pas de il y a plein de trucs à faire
pour les livres alors je vais commencer
par un livre de Philippe BX
ça c'est interdit vous avez compris
aussi il faut le citer ouais mais non
parce que moi j'aime bien alors le livre
de Philippe c'est l'âge de l'hôtel parce
que moi ce que j'aime bien c'est un
autre type que j'ai pas cité mais pour
moi c'est le prolongement du rapport du
Club de Rome c'est à dire qu'il a quand
même des solutions qui fonctionnent dans
un monde contraint contre un énergie il
écrit bien il y a un petit passage un
peu aride avant la moitié qu'un peu
technique mais une fois qu'on l'a passé
honnêtement ça donne des perspectives et
j'en connais pas d'autres l'autre
l'autre que je filtré d'occasion
maintenant on a suffisamment sur le
marché maintenant donc ça c'est quand
même intéressant je pense que il y a
beaucoup de solutions
aller chercher un autre que j'ai lu
récemment qui quand même la bande
dessinée de Jean-Marc Jancovici pour
ceux que le sujet intéresse qui est
quand même assez incroyable ce qu'il a
fait que Monsieur Blin j'ai plus son
prénom Christophe Blin il a quand même
réussi à moi ça fait plus de 15 ans que
je parle de sujet autour de moi ça
m'intéresse personne mais là je vois
tout le monde autour de moi qui a ce
livre là quoi ils n'ont pas forcément
jusqu'à la fin mais il a quand même
réussi à faire pénétrer le sujet dans
les chaumières il y a Maria De Soto qui
dit beaucoup de questions intéressantes
qui ne sont jamais posées alors Maria
pose une question tout de suite pendant
que Nicolas fille sa réponse et après le
troisième livre c'est un livre de
Barjavel qui s'appelle ravage qui est le
premier livre de sciences qui date de
1943 et qui se projette en
2040 quelque chose il y a à peu près là
où on est aujourd'hui ou du jour au
lendemain il y a plus d'énergie plus
l'électricité blackout
43 il fallait être un peu visionnaire
et ça nous montre un peu ce qui nous
attend c'est pas très gros ça vaut le
coup
et pour le Conseil
on va lui laisser 2 minutes de plus j'en
profite pour meubler que pour Maria tu
veux mon troisième bouquin du coup
pour les amateurs de SF effectivement la
guerre éternelle la guerre éternelle de
Joe Alderman comme c'est on est en
guerre là un peu un truc très sympa
écrit pendant écrit par un ancien du
Vietnam qui en fait une fable sur voilà
je vous en dis pas plus mais bien sympa
qui existe en BD aussi d'ailleurs ça a
été adapté alors on vous dit dans
l'oreillette que ils ont le droit de
poser une question que toutes les 10
minutes
donc on va attendre 10 minutes
débrouillez-vous
10 minutes
pendant que voilà pendant qu'on est en
train de gérer toutes les galères dans
tu es en train de Paris il y a des gens
qui essayent de nous faire croire que on
va aller tout se chausser des lunettes
de réalité virtuelle en rentrant du
boulot le soir je sais pas quoi voir
même aller au boulot comme ça aller à
l'école comme ça moi je trouve que c'est
en train de tourner tranquillement à la
pantalonnade on va on va attendre un
petit peu alors il faut pas négliger les
progrès possibles et puis quand on
embauche 10 000 personnes qui font j'en
sais rien de la programmation de jeux
vidéo ça peut finir par faire un truc
sympa mais qui va être évidemment
ultra énergivore très très complexe moi
je pense que ça va ça va faire un peu
comme hyper loop ça va faire un peu
comme comme les Smart City ça va ça va
ça va faire un flop voilà on verra en
tout cas c'est sympathique de voir que
c'est chahuter un peu en bourse et que
c'est en train de merdouiller c'est pas
la solution de sobriété à ceux qui
voulaient nous envoyer dans l'espace
dans des villes toutes construites etc
finalement ça coûte un peu moins cher on
va chez soi
[Rires]
du coup je dois rouler au sans plomb ou
à le 85 pour la planète
ressemblant pour les orang-outans le 85
alors ça coûte moins cher faut faire
attention déjà faut que votre voiture
elle faut que ça fonctionne moi j'ai
fait un petit test à ne pas reproduire
j'ai fait un petit test avec ma voiture
que tu avais de la pénurie puisque
j'avais plus d'essence et donc j'ai dû
faire j'ai dû prendre de l'E85 sans
transformation j'ai mis la moitié du
plein j'ai fait un plein à 20 euros à 80
centimes ça m'a fait bizarre je me dis
pourquoi est-ce que je paye comme un con
le triple du prix
et ça marchait très bien alors à ne pas
reproduire normalement il faut mettre un
boîtier il faut mettre un boîtier mais
je crois que c'est saisi pour les
démarrages à froid en hiver que ça pose
un problème mais a priori quand vous
mettez j'ai posé la question sur les
réseaux sociaux que tout le métier la
moitié du réservoir ou deux tiers ça
peut passer quand j'ai appelé mon
constructeur mon garagiste il m'a dit
dans cette surtout pas ça donc c'est pas
trop recommandé en cas de pénurie ça
peut ça peut dépanner
question de Maria mais mais mais c'est
une vieille question c'est obligé de
remonter dans le chat
faudrait-il mettre en place ce niveau
mondial de réelle barrières douanières
entre les zones économiques ou le coût
de la main d'oeuvre est-il identique
cela inciterait une relative autonomie
locale
oui non
bah moi je vais répondre juste quand
vous avez
c'est là où tu m'as coupé tout à l'heure
mais quand vous avez votre en France le
coût de l'industrie qui a 35 euros de
l'heure et qu'au Portugal il est à 8
3 à 4 fois moins cher donc je sais pas
où vous voulez mettre votre barrière
mais de toute façon déjà dans rien que
dans l'Europe entre nos salaires en
France ils puissent il se passe Portugal
et en Europe de l'Est voir en Ukraine ou
on a déjà on est où la barrière on
aimerait de Paris il faut faire de la
France on frontière de l'Europe vous
avez pas dans l'Europe vous avez pas le
droit de mettre de barrière donc alors
dans le même idée il y a pour le climat
il y a quelque chose qui avait été
évoqué qui était un club climat et ça
c'était par un économiste
[Musique]
et qui proposait à des pays comme nous
qui nous infligeons qui mettons une taxe
carbone très élevée de se dire dans ces
pays-là tous ces pays se mettaient
ensemble pour dire on met une taxe
carbone à 50 euros lactose 60 euros la
tonne et aux frontières de cet espace
qui n'est pas forcément contiguë qui
peut être la France le Canada et la
Chine et bien là vous avez une taxe à
l'importation pour compenser le montant
d'un taxe carbone et ça c'est quelque
chose qui me semble assez pertinent
parce que ça permet de partir avec un
petit ensemble de pays et que les gens
finalement
peuvent rejoindre ce club ils sont pas
obligés de payer la taxe et
on est capable de faire quelque chose
alors qu'aujourd'hui quand vous avez
quelque chose comme la COP 27 à 200
personnes ce dont vous êtes sûr c'est
qu'il y a rien qui sera décidé et si
c'est décidé ce sera quelque chose
d'assez fictif question internet en
attendant en arrière on va pas pouvoir
attendre longtemps
question de Shadok est-ce qu'il faut
financer la filière nucléaire à fond ou
pas
à fond ça veut dire quoi à fond
moi j'aurais tendance à dire que déjà on
a on a un existant on a déjà là qu'il
faut déjà entretenir qu'il faut un
entretenir de faire monter un peu de
niveau c'est des grands carénages en
termes de sécurité et 3 on a aussi de
toute manière des trucs qu'il faudra des
mots clés des déchets qu'il faudra gérer
etc donc de toute manière il faut
maintenir une filière nucléaire le coût
est parti on n'a pas le choix et donc il
faut que il faut que ça soit une filière
qui attire des jeunes qui se reformer
qu'à carte de l'expérience auprès des
autres et que cette cette expertise
organisationnelle se transmette qui est
pas un espèce de creux comme il y a eu
pendant 20 ans donc ça de toute façon ce
sera nécessaire après est-ce qu'il faut
construire pour ça trois paires de
prière 6 9 ou 12
ça va nous emmener très très loin mais
moi j'aurais tendance à dire modéré mais
je voulais juste rebondir un peu là
dessus et sur notre métaphore filer avec
Elizabeth borne pour faire Camille
comparaison avec
1973 73 chapitre 1 on utilise beaucoup
de fioules notamment pour produire de
l'électricité et là en 73 avec ce qui se
passe vous avez
Messmer qui arrive premier ministre bien
espère et qui annonce
la construction de 10 réacteurs en 5 ans
d'accord directeur de 1 milliard de
francs chacun en 5 ans
50 ans plus tard vous avez Elizabeth
borne toujours Premier ministre qui
vient à la télévision ou 20 heures de
TF1 le dimanche soir et qui vous annonce
une prolongation de 15 jours de la
ristourne
c'est ça qui s'est passé en 50 ans on a
quand même un problème de temps long on
a un problème de projection
et surtout on a un problème qui est que
il y a 50 ans on construisait un
réacteur en 5 ans et qu'aujourd'hui on
en faisait 1050 et qu'aujourd'hui un peu
plus si tu veux
ça prend 15 ans
ils ont été lancés juste après
l'élection de Mitterrand enfin
Mitterrand et le dernier le dernier qui
a été mis en service je crois que c'est
niveau je crois que c'est 97 donc c'est
vraiment on est dans le dans le disque
dans le 10-15 ans et pas forcément il
était à 7 huit ans j'ai vu les chiffres
il était un peu il y a eu un peu
d'inflation
aujourd'hui les réacteurs il y a des
conséquences
mais après bon c'est quand même pas mal
d'avoir un peu d'enquête publique un peu
de truc bah je sais pas est-ce qu'il
vraiment aller demander aux gens je suis
désolé est-ce qu'il faut faire du
nucléaire ou pas
mon pote ça va être tranquille ou je
suis dans le bois de Boulogne
les gens sont très contents il y a de la
taxi olympiques les gens sont fiers il y
a il y a de l'enfant
question internet pour Philippe
comme pour les jeunes générations tu
conseillerais quel le tech a développé
massivement
un commentaire qui a été fait dans le
chat qui est d'ailleurs désopilant la
barbe te va très bien merci
vas-y continue quel hôtel
pas la marmite norvégienne ou le frigo
du désert ou les voilà les objets un peu
emblématiques qu'on voit parfois en
disant oui c'est super et tout parce que
norvégienne
non non c'est un truc c'est qu'en fait
tu as une marmite qui est isolée et donc
elle garde de la chaleur et ça finit de
cuire en ayant arrêté les plaques
et donc c'est vachement intéressant
effectivement sauf l'hiver dans ton truc
où tu chauffes de toute manière avec une
grosse plaque électrique à côté par
contre l'été c'est intéressant mais
souvent tu fais des plats moins moins en
sauce ou je sais pas quoi ou des soupes
l'hiver va te faire plus l'hiver qui
était bon non mais c'est un exemple un
peu emblématique des lotexpress je
disais c'est facile à fabriquer soi-même
enfin voilà de rajouter un IS et tout
faites pas n'importe quoi prenez pas
n'importe quoi ça peut brûler et tout
donc aller voir des trucs sur internet
mais c'est bien de préciser
que moi je moi les lothèques pour moi
sont pas justes et sont pas vraiment des
objets d'une certaine manière c'est une
démarche c'est à dire que voilà la
démarche et de dire on fait de la
sobriété on essaie de faire du juste
dimensionnement on essaie de faire un
truc réparable on essaie de faire des
trucs modulaires on essaie d'avoir du
techno discernement c'est-à-dire de pas
mettre de l'électronique partout pour le
plaisir d'avoir des fioritures seulement
là où c'est utile tellement c'est
impactant d'un point de vue
environnemental et donc de ce point de
vue là ben on peut faire plein de trucs
on peut faire un Internet l'hôtel aller
au lieu d'avoir quatre réseaux d'accès
par exemple 5G 4G 3G 2G c'est quand même
ça qu'on a aujourd'hui en France ça
mutualise un peu mais pas beaucoup et
bien moi j'ai qu'un seul tuyau d'eau
j'ai qu'un seul tuyau de gaz j'ai qu'un
seul câble électrique qui arrive chez
moi pourquoi j'ai quatre réseaux 5G
ça arrive encore pour l'instant chez moi
mais je te dis pas où j'habite donc
voilà on pourrait par mutualiser voilà
je sais pas si c'est une démarche low
tech mais on pourrait tout à fait
mutualiser faire un seul réseau d'accès
qui soit d'ailleurs un peu limité un peu
pour pas faire du streaming on se
baladant à 300 km/h et ça ça
économiserait genre la moitié de la
facture électrique des réseaux télécom
en France c'est quand même pas
négligeable c'est on est en train de
parler de Terra water là de donc voilà
c'est un exemple ah ben voilà je suis
infiniment désolé les gars c'est pas une
petite question de c'est la question il
va falloir prendre du temps pour pour y
répondre
merci Maria question de Maria l'Europe
était en train de se suicider
énergétiquement en se coupant de la
Russie point d'interrogation
pourrait-elle faire une transition
énergétique pourra-t-elle faire une
transition énergétique point
d'interrogation
c'est pas enfin se suicider qu'est-ce
qu'on fait c'est quoi l'alternative
c'est faire un bisou sur la bouche à
Poutine et puis de dire ouais vous avez
raison allons faire une génuflexion
parce que on a vraiment besoin de ça moi
ça me paraît pas très raisonnable non
plus parce que à ce moment là quelle est
la concession d'aujourd'hui c'est quoi
et puis la concession de demain et
d'après demain c'est quoi fascisme
toujours très cher c'est ça
je pense qu'il faut avoir des principes
ouais je trouve ça pas mal d'ailleurs
j'avais ça me fait penser à François
Hollande qui avait fait une tribune tout
à fait improbable pour François Hollande
genre en mars 2022 il avait dit bah
ouais on aura un peu froid mais tant pis
au moins on aura respecté le principe
bah ouais quoi enfin je veux dire quand
même essayer de retrouver un peu de
peut-être de dignité il aura toujours un
peu plus
la question de l'égalité des efforts de
l'équité du partenaire etc bien sûr mais
donc moi je pense non par contre ce que
j'ai envie de dire c'est la transition
énergétique européenne française
européenne finalement elle doit être
massive mais ça vient forcément modifier
profondément les profils de consommation
et de production c'est à dire que si on
veut faire évidemment une transition
énergétique en continuant à construire
autant de berlines en construisant
autant de je sais pas quoi de
d'emballage qu'on jette en ayant
toujours autant de dépenses numériques
en étant vraiment dans ce monde du du
produit
utilisé jeté et puis des fois utiliser
c'est une journée et des fois utilisé
ces deux ans et des fois c'est dix ans
et bien ça marchera pas parce
qu'effectivement la quantité de
ressources qu'on entendra besoin
énergétique ou non énergétique et
tellement phénoménale que pendant ce
temps-là les autres envolent aussi et
puis même ce qui marchera pas c'est
effectivement la diplomatie
internationale parce que on n'aura pas
été capable d'inventer un nouveau modèle
de post- croissance devant un appel
comme on veut qu'il soit de pleine
emploi tant qu'à faire et avec de la
justice sociale et avec de la protection
sociale et avec des capacités à soigner
correctement et à traiter correctement
les anciens je sais pas quoi et bien
voilà ça marchera pas donc il qu'on
invente ce modèle là qui est à mon avis
3 à 4 fois moins énergivore
qu'aujourd'hui c'est c'est je viserai à
minima ça et encore une fois on revient
sur l'aspirateur qu'on change et je sais
pas quoi c'est pas juste être moins
heureux et que ça soit affreux et voilà
bah oui par contre faudra peut-être
faire moins de weekend à Barcelone et je
sais pas quoi est-ce qu'il faut envoyer
les gens qui s'arrose de champagne sur
des t-shirts mouillés en prison
disons que je trouve ça autrement quand
je suis influenceur et que j'habite à
Dubaï
peut-être quand tu as un petit pet tu
rentres pas de faire soigner dans un
hôpital français par exemple
tu assumes la liberté d'entreprendre
jusqu'au bout voilà c'est ça qui est un
peu gênant en fait c'est pour les
accepte il faut contribuer à hauteur de
bah non mais que voilà qu'on ait une
sorte de démission sociale un certain
nombre de personnes qui en plus peuvent
effectivement s'afficher mais par contre
je pense que voilà c'est les prisons
sont pleines ça va être compliqué sans
même plus que plein donc mais par contre
d'être capable d'envoyer des contrefeux
culturels
et pas laisser nos enfants de 10 ans en
perdition devant ça avec toute une série
de mécanismes qui
serait de se dire c'est quoi la norme
pour avoir un smartphone à quel âge pour
faire quoi pour qu'on numérise l'École
etc bah ouais ça je pense que c'est
important
[Rires]
Nicolas
sur la est-ce que tu veux que je répète
la question de Maria tu peux la répéter
précisément
l'Europe était en train de se suicider
énergétiquement on se coupant de la
Russie
pourra-t-elle faire une transition
énergétique
est-ce que l'Europe est en train de se
suicider
je pense qu'elle était de toute façon
pas en bonne posture que on était sous
contrainte
énergétique et que tôt ou tard ça allait
arriver là effectivement l'agenda s'est
accéléré depuis le début de l'année et
nous force justement à faire cette
transition énergétique que l'on n'a pas
voulu faire depuis 20 ans
qui aurait imaginé qu'Emmanuel Macron
parle de sobriété le discours du 14
juillet personne sous toutes ses tables
on aurait aimé qu'il en parle plutôt
mais donc moi c'est ce que je dis quand
je suis un petit peu taquin c'est que
finalement Vladimir Poutine a fait plus
pour le climat que les 27 premières cops
donc oui mais c'est vrai il a forcé la
majeure partie du boulot mais c'est pas
ce que je veux dire c'est pas mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que aujourd'hui
on commence effectivement contraint et
forcé à faire cette transition on savait
on l'a dit avec Philippe que une grande
part ça va être de la sobriété ça va
être de mieux s'organiser et qu'on est
d'ailleurs capable d'avoir le même
niveau de service d'accord sans posséder
chacun des choses donc sans baisser son
niveau de vie mais on va devoir plus
partager les choses matérielles puisque
notre niveau de vie matérielle par
personne va baisser donc ça c'est des
choses et d'ailleurs moi c'est ce que je
quand je fais des conférences au sujet
on me dit toujours que j'ai oublié de
venir avec ma valise de lexomiline mais
je suis quand même très je suis très
optimiste parce qu'en fait on est un pic
du monde matérialiste qui correspond en
même temps corrélation n'étant pas
causalité un pic des antidépresseurs
donc on va revenir un petit peu sur
terre c'est pas l'abondance de matériel
qui nous a rendu heureux on va
redescendre à des niveaux un peu plus
descend on va faire augmenter la partie
immatérielle la culture on va retrouver
du lien social avec les gens avec notre
famille on va plus rester tanqué sur le
téléphone on va prendre plus de temps
plus de temps avec les gens et on va
essayer de faire beaucoup mieux avec
avec moins
donc moi je suis plutôt optimiste pour
la suite mais par contre effectivement
presque l'Europe s'est suicidé c'est
compliqué de dire que l'Europe est
située par contre c'est sûr que sans
énergie bon marché a priori on va être
dans une phase quand même de
désindustrialisation finale la
conséquence de ça pas vous la dire
aujourd'hui mais ça va être compliqué
une petite dernière question qui nous
vient qui nous vient du Canada
est-ce que les groupes d'un français
est-ce que les groupes de supermarchés
et central d'achat sont sensibles ou
manque à venir en énergie fossile qui
expose leur modèle de grande
distribution
moi j'en ai pas rencontré donc je
saurais pas dire alors que ça m'est
arrivé d'être contacté de 6 de là par
des boîtes plus industrielles on va dire
donc je saurais pas dire moi je l'ai
rencontré il y a pas très longtemps
je pense qu'ils sont pas préparés mais
je leur ai dit attention on regardait
des scénarios à 2040 je leur dis 2040
prenez que mes hypothèse qui a plus de
voiture
et organisez-vous pour que les gens
parce que leur modèle c'est la bagnole
si les gens ont pas de bagnole ils
peuvent payer dans les supermarchés et
donc je leur ai dit bah faites un
scénario sur la voiture et voyez comment
ça fonctionne
pour les jeunes générations et on en
terminera là
j'avais voulu faire du recyclage parce
que j'étais venu effectivement il y a 7
ans et je vais parler de d'un pull et
d'un pull et d'un vélo mais je vais
plutôt rebondir sur comme ça ça me
permet de faire deux sur ce qualifie
c'est qu'aujourd'hui je trouve que
notamment les jeunes
tout est fait pour les
plonger je trouve dans l'inaction pour
qu'il fasse rien alors que c'est eux qui
vont faire changer les choses et c'est
chacun à son petit niveau qui peut faire
sa part il faut rien attendre de
personne mais que si tout le monde fait
sa part et c'est ce que Philippe et moi
on a fait un moment donné et ce qu'on
essaie de faire tous les jours
et bien c'est que ensemble qu'on y
arrivera donc il faut surtout rien
attendre des autres et il faut pas
oublier et ça ça vient pas de moi mon
voisin que l'homme est là depuis 40000
ans qui s'est adapté depuis 40000 ans il
va pas disparaître du jour au lendemain
en Europe en Europe
c'est plutôt deux trois sens de 300000
ans tu vas te faire fâcher
et donc on va pas disparaître demain on
va aller vers un monde différent un
monde le monde d'après mais moi je pense
que on va pouvoir se recentrer et que
c'est pas forcément une mauvaise chose
mais on a besoin de tout tout le monde
ne vous dites pas que vous n'y pouvez
rien au contraire chacun peut faire sa
part il y a malheureusement que comme ça
qu'on pourra faire quelque chose
ça fait des dizaines de milliers
d'années que l'humanité règne sans
compter sur cette planète mais on se
fait toujours la guerre et il faudra
peut-être interdire un jour la guerre
messieurs bonsoir salut
[Musique]